it's that time of year again to look at
one of the most popular powerful and
most creative companies out there Disney
but the truth is Disney's been pretty
busy since I started Disney cember
buying up a lot of other very popular
and creative properties two of the ones
I've gotten the most attention are
Marvel and Star Wars two universes that
Disney has breathed life into unlike
anything we've seen before Marvel now
has a gigantic Cinematic Universe that
all connects and one of the most popular
film series of all time has been reborn
making up for what many consider the
sins of the past well seeing how these
are not only under Disney but have given
birth to some gigantic creative realms
it only seems fitting to take a look at
these two the downside is there's not
enough Marvel or Star Wars yet to fill
up the entire month so once again I'll
be looking at all the ones I haven't
touched on yet all the Disney movies
they've yet to be given the Disney
cember treatment and naturally not only
will I be looking at all the Marvel
movies and Star Wars movies as well as
the special editions but I'll be going
over the new ones coming out like the
good dinosaur and of course the force
awakens now as many of you know
copyright has gotten even tighter over
the years so just to be safe we're gonna
be using images on this one but they're
still the same way and there's still the
same opinions that you would expect or
maybe not expect you just have to watch
to find out it's the biggest mishmash of
properties ever but hey that's Disney
for you and we're here to look analyze
and have fun with some of the most
enjoyable films so sit back everybody
this is Disney cember the Marvel Star
Wars and everything else
[Music]
I guess it only figures to start off
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe
seeing how much it's changed things and
how incredibly long going it is and this
universe began with Iron Man going in I
mean very little about the comic I knew
it was just a guy in a metal suit who
flew around and shot up stuff I had no
idea the backstory the characters or
anything like that so was kind of nice
going in with fresh eyes and nothing to
really compare it to Robert Downey jr.
plays Tony Stark a technology obsessed
billionaire who likes to make weapons of
destruction he's arrogant a playboy and
totally full of himself but that all
changes when a terrorist group kidnaps
in and forces him to make a weapon for
them he befriends another kidnapped
technician and they decide rather than
make the weapon that they want they make
one to get the hell out of there under
the guise of a terrorist bomb after
creating a pretty badass suit and
escaping
Tony decides to devote his life to no
longer destroying lives but rather
saving thus he puts together the Iron
Man suit starts flying around the world
and stopping trouble wherever he sees
the only problem is his partner
businessman played by Jeff Bridges
doesn't like the changes he's made and
tries to make his own robotic suit to
stop it along with his secretary pepper
possibly by quinna Paltrow and his
bodyguard played by John Farrow the film
director its high flying technology to
see who can do the least amount of
damage and the most amount of damage
again having no idea how much this
connects to the comic I have to say the
story for this is brilliant we've seen
these kind of tales all the time the
Moses story where someone is bad goes
into exile and comes back a hero but
here it's a good update with our
obsession on technology this makes a lot
of sense and Tony Stark represents
everything that people want to be
nowadays they want to be obsessed with
technology but they also kind of want to
be full of themselves they want to be
doing good things but they want to have
the badass one-liners they want to be
smooth but they want to be troubled they
want a life of luxury but still doing
some pretty badass things creating the
best with the best and the best from the
least it's also nice to see a superhero
we haven't seen in a while that has
technology that probably doesn't exist
now but you could see existing kind of
soon and he doesn't just use gadgets
like Batman does he surrounds himself in
the
technology it's all down to his wits and
the best thing about it is that it comes
from a brilliant mind he doesn't just
rely on people to build it he builds a
lot of it himself as well he's a guy who
utilizes every resource that he can and
yet he's still so crazy in some respects
he's a drunk and a loser and a womanizer
and he's just kind of a dick but his
need to want to do good especially from
such a troubled past makes him so
incredibly interesting and at the center
of that is Robert Downey Jr who makes
this movie now don't get me wrong this
is still a good film but if it wasn't
for him it wouldn't be half the movie it
was this is the ultimate comeback
performance this guy has had a shaky
past and now he's the movie star
everybody wants to beat he always has
the great one-liner and even if he
doesn't he can say it so that it sounds
like a great one-liner just like the
transformation of the Iron Man character
this guy is transformed as well in many
respects staying the same but in others
making the exact right choices at the
exact right time now is it perfect
no there are a few problems especially
in the second half this movie reminds me
a lot of Batman Begins where the first
half is some of the best exposition and
build-up for a back story ever and the
second half one I had to get to the
action is kind of underwhelming yeah
it's neat seeing him fly around in that
metal suit but he doesn't really do that
much action with it and the big battle
at the end is just against another guy
in an even bigger suit and yeah
something about that just seems kind of
dull at first Jeff Bridges who's kind of
unrecognizable in this seems like he'd
be a really good villain but then when
he puts that dumb looking outfit on he
just kind of looks like a video game fan
even the lines he says are kind of corny
and he says them kind of corny and I
don't know this wasn't the movie we
started out with this is more like how
the Disney Channel would do a superhero
climax not this movie it's not got all
four laughably bad it's just not as
engaging as the first half but the stuff
that's good is just too damn good the
male lead is likable the technology is
inventive the story is solid and very
easy to understand and relate with the
comedy is fresh the side characters are
entertaining it's just a good strong
superhero flick I guess I should
probably mention the after credit
sequence which now
was played at the end of every Marvel
movie with Samuel Jackson as Nick Fury
saying that he's starting up a team now
some people out there got really excited
because they knew he's talking about the
Avengers but he's the thing a lot of
movies had to be continues at the end
and after the credits and a lot of times
they never went anywhere so even though
there's that little hint nobody really
got that excited yet everybody kind of
thought oh yeah would it be cool if that
happened but nobody actually was
thinking oh yeah it's happening this big
universe where everybody's gonna get
their own movie and they're all gonna
come together yeah this is gonna be one
of the biggest things to happen to
blockbusters ever it was just a little
tease to show what could happen but none
of us knew what was actually lying ahead
and now looking back it's kind of cool
about these little end-credit sequences
that people used to just roll their eyes
at and say yeah I'll believe it when I
see it now people look forward to at
Marvel movies because they've come
through because they proven themselves
because they say hey when we give a hint
this is coming it's really coming it's
interesting to watch it now years later
knowing what this little teaser was
gonna lead to little do we know that
this was actually a fantastic start to a
cinematic universe that was about to
explode
[Music]
let's continue looking at the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with the Incredible
Hulk now it's impossible to talk about
this movie without talking about the
film version that came before the Hulk
many people regard it not as one of the
worst comic-book movies ever made but
one of the biggest comic-book mistakes
ever made the movie was directed by
Angley who just got done doing Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon this is a very good
talented director but he was obviously
the wrong one for this the movie was too
abstract who dramatic who slow paced and
somehow made the story of a giant green
man who smashes things boring so it was
pretty tough to do a reboot several
years later with that bad taste dil in
our mouths isn't much better than the
last one well yeah but it's still not
that yeah ok let's look at the story the
film brilliantly starts off with an
opening credits sequence that actually
kind of shows what happened in the
previous film Bruce Banner is a
scientist who discovers this formula
that makes him a green monster endangers
his girlfriend who's the daughter of a
general gets chased by the military and
disappears into the Amazon that is the
exact plot of the previous film and yet
it's not exactly a sequel if you came
into this film not seeing the first one
you could just see it as oh this is the
backstory of this character but there's
just enough little changes that you
could see it as a reboot it's very very
clever that way in my opinion is
probably the smartest thing in the movie
Bruce Banner this time is played by
Edward Norton which seems like a good
choice he spends his time now in the
jungle trying to find a cure for his
condition but the army as well as his
girlfriend played this time they live
Tyler are still on the lookout for one
man volunteers as guinea pig played by
Tim Roth who also chases banner while
starting to get injections turning
himself into a giant green monster
thus the movie ends with Hulk vs. Hulk
with one giant green monster pounding
another giant green monster in a city on
paper it sounds like this would be done
a lot better and even in the film it
kind of is Edward Norton is a very good
replacement and he does a great job in
the role I'm always impressed how a guy
with such a baby face and a high-pitched
voice can come off as such an
intelligent badass everything he says
just sounds legitimate you know he's not
bullshit
around ever Tim Blake Nelson plays a
good scientist who may or may not be
evil and Tim Roth once again is a very
enjoyable villain the surprising
downside of this movie is that once
again the wow factor is very minimal
at first the build-up is great you see
the Hulk in the shadows it's kind of
hard to make him out he makes this
appearance in a factory behind the smoke
and it's really good but then the more
you see of them the less impressive he
seems to be I mean yeah he growls and
snorts and jumps around and throws
things but when you think of a Hulk
movie you want to see the Hulk do really
cool stuff even the first film at least
had some scenes rais'd throwing a tank
and jumping on planes here he's just
kind of running around and I know the
argument should the focus be on Bruce
Banner and his emotional struggle and
all that stuff sure but it's still
called The Incredible Hulk and we want
to see the Hulk do something incredible
and you just don't see much of that in
this film even the complicated plan from
the villain kind of seems out of nowhere
and I know you can make the argument
yeah the serums and everything they're
making him crazy but haven't we seen
that a lot of times before hasn't it
been done a lot better when you see
their descent with this guy it just
seems like oh I want to stop him because
it's my mission and now I'm just kind of
nuts I don't know Javert he ain't help
even Javert is a Javert but that's in
our story it also feels like they're
setting up some things that now in
hindsight don't really go anywhere like
there's a scene where Tim Blake Nelson
gets knocked out and ECM almost kind of
go through a weird transformation you
think oh what's this gonna be is this
gonna be a new villainous it's gonna be
a new bad guy but no he never appears in
a of the other movies at least not that
I know of on the whole I guess I wasn't
really upset that I saw it or anything I
didn't feel like a time was wasted it
just didn't feel like it was anything
that spectacular or even really that
interesting it was the perfect
definition of okay you wanna see Edward
Norton be okay you want to see Tim Roth
be okay you want to see the effects be
okay that's what you're gonna get an
okay movie but again it's the Incredible
Hulk why are we only getting okay with
the Incredible Hulk I don't know I know
this movie kind of got panned when it
came out and I don't think it's quite
that
and like I said I don't even really
think it's really terrible by any means
it's just kind of underwhelming once
again though I have to talk about the
after credit sequence in this one you
think the movies over and they're just
gonna have a little throwaway joke at
the end but out of nowhere suddenly
there's Robert Downey jr. as Tony Stark
this is very common nowadays for Marvel
movies but back then you never saw this
you never saw an a-list actor from a
Marvel movie suddenly come in saying hey
matter that thing we teased at the end
of our other film we're really fuckin
doing it and this is when Robert Downey
jr. suddenly exploded as this big
celebrity so to suddenly see him pop in
at the end
not just for a little laugh but actually
saying yeah we're holding true to our
promises it was actually kind of
chilling people suddenly start to say
holy smokes are they really doing this
our Iron Man and a Hulk gonna be in a
movie and if so does that mean we're
gonna get Thor Captain America and God
knows how many other Avengers are out
there
the idea was suddenly seeming possible
so I guess in a very strange way the
most incredible part of the Incredible
Hulk was the credits and I guess you
could take that as an insult but they
were done really well the less I say
about the rest of the movie like I said
it's pass not good not bad just passable
if you're in the mood to see a Hulk film
that's better than the first one but
still doesn't quite reach that level of
incredible miss give it a rent it's
worth a few hours of your time
[Music]
Iron Man 2 the sequel to one the biggest
superhero films that ever came out at
the end of the last Iron Man movie we
see a superhero do something that I
don't think I've ever seen a superhero
do in a movie he reveals his secret
identity to the world when does that
ever happen it's always to a love
interest or a close friend or something
like that whoever just admits to the
world that they're a superhero it's
something I've never seen before and got
me really excited for the sequel because
you would think wow this is gonna go
places we've never seen a superhero
movie bill before and in some respects
it does we see the life of a superhero
if he was a celebrity Tony Stark has
taken the law into his own hands as
flying around the world and stopping
evil wherever he sees it and the
government kind of a confusing way is
powerless to stop it he's more popular
than ever everybody loves him and of
course he has his vengeful haters Mickey
Rourke is a villain who vows vengeance
against Tony Stark because of some
wrongdoing that his father did in the
past
he attaches these electric ropes to his
hands and suddenly he's one hell of a
badass bum but that's not the only thing
going wrong Tony's heart is slowly
giving out because of the electronic
device that he's using to keep him alive
has put so eloquently the device that's
keeping him alive is also slowly killing
him on top of that he's upgraded Pepper
Potts to take over his business a new
bodyguard named Black Widow play
famously now by Scarlett Johansson
enters the mix and another big
corporation wants to take down Stark by
teaming up with work and creating even
better war machines in fact one of them
is even called war machine when this
film came out people hated it all they
could do is talk about how god-awful it
was now don't get me wrong it's still
doing really good at the box office but
everybody just despised the hell of it
does the film deserve such a bashing
Jane dude but I don't know if it deserve
quite as much as a gun I guess I'll talk
about the good stuff first it does show
kind of the price of celebrity Tony of
course loves the attention but he
realizes that he can't escape himself
no matter how hard he parties or gets
drunk all his misery is always waiting
there for him except now it's in public
and everybody can see it when he gets in
a fight with a best friend suddenly it
makes news and it makes it even harder
for him to figure out how to solve his
problems
Mickey Rourke as well is a great choice
for a villain he has a wonderful boys he
has a perfect look he has the strength
he just came off of a huge hit movie
it's an ideal choice but this does all
build up to the biggest problem with the
movie it goes nowhere
remember that problem with Tony's heart
if they'll cut that out and not miss
anything
you know how Mickey Rourke is spending
most of the movie building these
incredible weapons it's only around a
few minutes at the end he'll you know
how Mickey Rourke is supposed to be the
villain in this you barely see them in
fact the main bad guy is just some
asshole in a suit wait do we already
have some asshole in a suit in the last
movie yeah we get it big business bad
but come on we just dealt with this guy
when there is fighting in the movie it
doesn't really connect to anything that
big or epic Ironman fights with his
friend well ok it looks cool but who
cares would it be cool that Mickey
Rourke man I mean they're friends
fighting we know they're gonna make up
we know they're gonna figure things out
why are we spending so much time seeing
them fight at a party remember how stark
upgraded Pepper Potts to run the company
she doesn't like it she turns it down
after a while
okay well what's the point of that then
there's a lot of time dedicated to Tony
and remembering his father what a jerk
he was only to figure out he wasn't
really that much of a jerk okay what did
that add Tony still acts like a jerk and
that's the fun kind of jerk just a jerk
jerk he gets drunk and keeps telling
everybody that despite what they think
he knows what he's doing but he doesn't
he clearly doesn't know what he's doing
and it's not fun to watch in the first
film he did jerky things but he still
came around to using his brilliant mind
he utilized stuff he was resourceful
here all the times he reassures people
they knows what he's doing it never
comes back into play
thank God they tackle Black Widow a lot
better in the future
because she's kind of a waste of
character here so yeah the film does
have a lot of problems and in the end
probably doesn't really work but the
strength of it does still come from the
cool stuff that we like to see in an
Iron Man movie we like to see the
technology we like to see the one-liners
and again we like to see Robert Downey
jr. doing the role that redefined him
even when he's being such a pain in the
ass he is still so funny and so
enjoyable to watch which is why it's
such a letdown when you find out that he
actually doesn't know as much as he's
letting on and that he is just getting
drunk and acting like an ass so I don't
know I guess it's bad but I still think
there's some really neat things in there
they haven't been done yet like tackling
the celebrity of a superhero who
revealed himself the technology is upped
a little bit and kind of see Iron Man
doing the typical Iron Man stuff there's
just not as much as you would like in
the end it just kind of feels like a
distraction to introduce a few other
elements in between Marvel movies I
guess I feel a little bad for it because
everybody praised what a masterpiece the
first movie was and yeah it's good it's
well done but it had problems too and
everyone seems to forget that when they
look at this one it doesn't work as a
whole but I don't think it's as bad as
everybody else built it up to be and I
guess we kind of know that there's more
Iron Man movies on the way anyway so
it's not like this is the last one we
would ever see now how would that one
fare up well we'll get to that when we
get to that but for this one it's
probably the perfect definition of close
but no explode
[Music]
so out of all the Marvel superheroes
that we're getting get their movies the
one I was probably the most concerned
about was Thor because with all the
other superheroes it kind of made sense
they'd get superpowers or their based on
technology or they create stuff
Thor was a god how do you do that and on
top of that his design was always kind
of weird he had a helmet with these
weird wings on it I just remember
thinking to myself oh man this is gonna
be the one this is the one that people
are just gonna roll their eyes at and
say sorry Marvel we can't do it it's
just too goofy but they made the very
clever choice of the signing Kenneth
Branagh to direct it now this is a guy
that hasn't really done any superhero
movies and to be fair he can be kind of
hit and miss but he's got mad talent and
everything he does is huge and this
movie is no exception this is a gigantic
looking film suddenly the idea of Marvel
telling the story of a god sounds
unbelievable look at Thor he looks
amazing look at Odin he looks amazing
we'll look at this environment it's
freaking phenomenal which is why it's
really ironic that the least impressive
part of this movie is what Marvel
usually does well the interaction with
the real world yep they just decide to
make this a fish out of water story with
Thor pissing off his father Odin and
Odin banishing him to the world of Earth
taking away his powers he spends his
time befriending a group of scientists
one of them played by Natalie Portman
learning how to be a true humble hero
and figuring out how to get back to stop
his sinister brother Loki from taking
over the throne so on the one hand you
might think the stuff where he goes to
earth is beyond painful and to its
credit it's not is it
good well I don't know if I can say that
but much like Iron Man a lot of the
likeability comes from the charm of the
main actor Chris Hemsworth is a perfect
Thor he can be cocky but like ibly naive
he has a lot of anger but you know deep
down he's a gentle guy and most
importantly of all he adapts
I'm so sick of these movies were the
fish-out-of-water just days stubborn and
never wants to change anything but this
guy he's a warrior he's fought in
battles so when he throws a cup of
coffee on the ground demanding more and
they tell him that's not how we do
things here he doesn't demand an
explanation or act like a spoiled brat
he says okay this is what makes the
movie work he actually evolves he
actually changes because of this we can
stomach a lot more the traditional stuff
which with that being said it is pretty
traditional the lump in treads and side
characters on earth are not very
interesting the battle scenes are kind
of standard and yeah was this the best
story you could have done with the idea
of Thor probably not but luckily they do
often come back to the world of the gods
and every time it does it looks amazing
you feel the gigantic size and weight of
this again even though it never loses
track that it's still a comic book in my
opinion maybe one of the greatest
looking comic book movies ever does this
do I make a whole lot of sense not
particularly is it especially engaging
no there's nothing really that new but
the way it's acted and the way it's
shown makes it a lot of fun I wish they
didn't have to do this story where he
travels to earth but it's passable and
anytime it's not on earth it's really
freaking cool we do get a few battles in
this realm and we do feel this
frustration between the brothers Loki
and Thor and though maybe kind of
awkwardly and over time Loki does become
a pretty good villain I guess you could
still look at all this and say it's
still pretty silly but it's just so
epically silly
I love how seriously everybody is taking
this look at the expressions on their
faces look at these visuals this looks
like something out of some grand
mythology so I guess the best way I can
describe it is if you want to see Thor
being Thor you'll get it it just got
away through some predictable standard
stuff but as that predictable standard
stuff goes it's not as bad as you would
think is it needed probably not but
again remembering the time period this
came out it's not like everybody was
just ready to accept a Thor movie this
was probably the best compromise you can
get it
the grand stuff is still grand and it
sucks me into its world do I wish there
was more of it hell yeah but for what I
got I really enjoyed it yes I could have
used more action and even more
exploration of these worlds but for what
I thought I was gonna get I was
thoroughly impressed not the best by any
means but impressive enough for me
[Music]
well if there was any Marvel character I
was more afraid not to take seriously
than Thor it would definitely be Captain
America not only was his design so silly
with the bright blue the giant bullseye
and the little wings on the side of his
head but there was already a movie made
in the 80s that looked like it was made
in the 70s that big shock was not very
good in fact there's even a nostalgic
reg review of it so once again I was a
little hesitant to see what they were
gonna do with this
but luckily once again they turned out a
pretty good product
Captain America starts off as a wimpy
little soldier conveyed through some
pretty impressive computer-generated
effects not to say it's flawless but you
gotta look really hard to notice his
good will and courage convinces
everybody that he'd be perfect for a new
experiment one that could lead to a
league of superhumans that could stop
Hitler and his Nazi thugs he agrees to
the experiment and gets turned into a
beefcake but the scientist has killed
thus he's the only super soldier of Ares
one of the problems though is that
nobody knows what to do with him he's
seen as a hero to many so rather than
actually put him in combat they just
kind of put him in advertisements Big
Show's dance numbers all sorts of good
stuff promoting the good of the war but
he's not really doing that many heroics
finally they agree to send him into
combat and he does a great job that is
until he comes across the evil Red Skull
played by Hugo Weaving Direction
adventurers stunts and all sorts of
great effects Captain America fights off
Nazis and saves the day more times than
you can count again not having read that
much Captain America I didn't really
know what to expect from this film and I
also wasn't really sure if this was
gonna catch on in a market where we like
things they're new and current and this
takes place back in the 40s but through
some good writing some fun stunts and
again some very likeable actors this
movie turns out to be a good adventure
yeah I use the word adventure it's not
really as much of an action don't get me
wrong there's lots of fistfights and
great stunts but I don't know maybe the
40 setting makes me think a little bit
more of like Errol Flynn and flying
planes and spinning around adventure
just feels like the more proper word the
director of this movie also directed The
Rocketeer and it really shows this guy
knows how to make the time period
look good they also boast are very
similar main characters who are not dull
but not the most interesting either but
they're good they're sort of the typical
hero you would see in the 40s very
simple but very likeable naive but
always looking to do good even some of
the typical cliches are played with a
little bit like there's a scene where
this guy grabs this kid and he throws
him in the water trying to escape he's
about to jump in and save the kid but
the kid says no go after him I can swim
God isn't that refreshing but Marvel
movies really do seem to have this great
technique of taking cliches that exist
and either playing with them or only
taking the best aspects of them the ones
most people are tired of they kind of
say yeah we're not doing that we know
you don't like them and we know you
think they're boring so we're only gonna
stick to the ones that are classic
furries and this one does have a lot of
the classics the bad guy with the
disfigured face the triumphant symbols
of America everywhere the heroic stunts
the mad scientists all that good stuff
it's light-hearted but it doesn't steer
away from some heavier moments either
when somebody dies it really feels like
they die and when some characters are
separated by a long distance or even
time you do feel legitimately bad if I
do have one major criticism of the movie
it's with the villain I know it sounds
strange but this is the one thing the
80s film actually did better that is
when they actually show them through
most of the original film that couldn't
show the Red Skull and he looked pretty
ridiculous but when they did show up he
looked fleshy he looked creepy he had
these beady eyes he had this great voice
keep believing his final when he just
looks like a human but then when he rips
off the mask and shows his real face it
looks pretty lame it just looks like a
plastic mask where the other one looked
really juicy the villain as well is kind
of a little dull nothing remember being
like really annoying or stupid or
anything I just don't remember that much
about him that does seem to be the one
weakness of the Marvel films is while
they do a great job or train the heroes
they don't usually portray the villains
that interestingly I remember Red Skull
was a big bad guy like this was a really
intimidating villain he was the one
Captain America always fought here he's
just kind of like any bad guy you see in
any other movie not insultingly bad or
anything just kindest
and part of a hero's journey is how
intimidating the threat is that he's
going up against so if the threat isn't
that intimidating you don't get as
invested but like I said he's not
horrible just not anything that great
but honestly much like Thor this was a
film I didn't think they could really do
I didn't think anybody could take
Captain America seriously but watching
it I actually found myself doing ok it
was clever that they just painted the
wings on the side of his helmet it was
clever the changes that they made to his
outfit and it's even more clever than in
future movies they would update the
outfit to fit the rest of the Avengers
this is a Marvel movie that you can tell
is kind of a segue but unlike Iron Man 2
it feels more natural it stands on its
own as a good movie it has a good
beginning middle and end it has a good
journey
it has good character arts it has good
concerns if the villain was a little
stronger it probably would have stood
out a little bit more but as is it was
once again really impressed I wanted to
know what was gonna happen to Captain
America next after the credits rolled at
this point I was finally realizing
Marvel is really making traditional
comic book movies work they didn't have
to pretend to be anything else or talked
down to you or hide behind anything with
just a few cleverly planned out updates
they were making comic book movies that
comic book fans have always wanted to
see and even better yet they were giving
a wider audience comic book films that
they didn't even know they wanted to see
these films were showing why these
stories were successful why people got
into them why they were worth making
movies about again I'm not gonna act
like this was the greatest one or
anything but it is the point where I
realized if you truly embrace a world
and an environment you don't need to
make as many changes as you thought and
with the end credits advertising that
the next big movie was gonna be the
Avengers the ultimate cement of Marvel
staying power was about to take place
[Music]
so after years and years of buildup all
the hype has finally come to this V
Avengers there has never been a movie
quite like this done before six previous
film starring individual superheroes
that were all coming together for one
event that was planned from the very
beginning though you could look at them
as individual stories they were all
leading up to one grand event this was
the event now don't get me wrong there
have been crossovers before but nothing
like this and nothing this well
thought-out so there was a little bit of
a concern would it pay off this would
definitely have a good opening weekend
no matter what it's been filled up so
much but would it be the gigantic hit
everybody wanted would it be as good as
the other Marvel movies or as promised
even better
ten times better something spectacular
Lee huge well the short answer is yes
not only was this film a mega mega mega
mega hit but both critics and audiences
alike agree it was a ton of fun and
worth the wait the movie centers around
the return of the sinister Loki he
apparently is in cahoots with an evil
force in space who wants to what else
take over the world of course he plans
to do so using a magic scepter to
hypnotize people and a gigantic alien
army to open up a dimension and bring
him into our world and slaving mankind
who can stop them
The Avengers of course most of them just
having come off hit movies Iron Man
Captain America Thor and even the Hulk
played this time by Mark Ruffalo but
also included our characters we haven't
seen that much of like Black Widow and
Hawkeye and the film literally from this
point on is nothing but one-liners and
action and I know it sounds strange but
it's actually kind of perfect when you
see these characters together a lot of
them with big personalities just having
come off of big movies what do you want
to see you want to see them interact
that includes working off of each other
talking to each other getting in fights
throwing insults and because these
actors and characters are so strong and
so defined it really works the whole
movie could be all of them just stuck in
a room shooting the shit and you know
what it'd be okay
they're that interesting and that much
fun to watch but of course that's not
what people are paying to see they're
paying to see action and when the action
gets going it's some of the most fun
I've seen an audience have in a movie
theater every superhero has a unique way
of fighting a villain and each one has a
different personality trait to make it
interesting well for the most part we
don't really know Hawkeye yet but yeah
we're not Avengers - yeah give it time a
lot of these movies as I mentioned
before deliver a lot of character but
sometimes skimp a little bit on the
action particularly in the climax the
great thing about this movie is that it
makes you think it's about to end they
do the big team shot you think all right
well they're just gonna punch out a few
more and then we're gonna stop but nope
it's just beginning they spend a lot of
time fighting creatures in the city and
unlike transformers you don't get tired
of it it gives you the exact amount you
want to see every superhero does what
you want to see the superheroes do The
Hulk jumps around and smashes things he
punches this giant whale I don't know
what is Captain America is throwing his
shield Iron Man flying around shooting
stuff even Black Widow who we didn't see
that much before this movie suddenly
becomes this really cool character she
actually might be my favorite out of all
of them and yeah I'm waiting for that
damn movie - the one element of the film
that is kind of lazy is the story but to
its credit story is not what you want to
focus on here this is the first time
you've seen all these characters come
together and you just want to see them
be those characters and beat shit up so
the story is very minimal hell it
doesn't even really make that much sense
Loki wants to get all the Avengers
together knowing they won't get along
and that would somehow destroy them
okay well as Tony Stark himself said not
a great plan the whole story is kind of
like that there's all these weird little
conveniences that don't really add up
and are kind of confusing but really you
don't care you're there to see The
Avengers fly around and be the Avengers
and this movie gives you that in bucket
loads they have been hyping this thing
up forever one of the biggest Marvel
teams of all time actually comes to the
big screen and it delivers does a
that much drama no is there that much
thinking in it absolutely not
but it's just an incredibly fun dumb
summer film this is the kind of movie
you want to see kind of mindless you
want to see a lot of dumb explosions but
it's done with so much wit and humor
that you find yourself enjoying even the
silliest moments it's nice to see a
cinematic gamble like this payoff and
for the right reasons if we just started
off with this movie before Iron Man
Captain America and all the other films
it wouldn't be as good it'd be
impressive but it'd just be too jumbled
because you wouldn't have all the
characters defined well now that we do
know all these characters and we enjoy
them and they certainly proven
themselves to be entertaining they come
together beautifully I even kind of find
myself enjoying Mark Ruffalo as the Hulk
I'll admit I like it where Norton just a
little bit more because I think he's
such an engaging actor but I like the
take he does he plays it as a guy who's
been spending years trying to achieve in
her call so he kind of looks half awake
sometime but it's actually intentional
it doesn't seem lazy at all it seems
like a guy who's just trying to keep his
rage under control because he knows
what'll happen with it and so he
sacrifices some of his stronger emotions
to keep everything balanced it would
have been cool to see Norton but this
guy is a good replacement what else can
I say it's the Avengers one of the
highest-grossing films of all time one
of the most hyped up films of all time
and it gave you exactly what you wanted
it's silly it's funny it's over-the-top
it's a comic book movie that no part in
it can you say it's not a comic book
movie it just drenches itself in it and
after years and years these were seen as
embarrassing films to make now they
completely won us over and everybody is
trying to do exactly what the Avengers
did create a movie universe something
that can continue and all these other
characters can interact with each other
and come in at different ideas they can
all try it and some even succeed but
none of us will forget who did it first
why because it was just so damn fun
[Music]
Iron Man 3 a film everyone agrees is
better than the last one
and that's about it people are split
about whether or not this is actually a
really good entertaining film but once
again it almost doesn't matter because
it stars the person you all come to see
Robert Downey jr. I began to think you
can put this guy as Tony Stark in Batman
and Robin and he would somehow still
make it work but with that aside does
the film actually work as a whole well
it depends on the point of view you're
coming from
ok so Tony Stark is back in his hometown
after the events of the Avengers one
major downside though is that now he's
getting panic attacks yeah kind of out
of nowhere they tried to explain it that
yeah if you go through this you might
get panic attacks too but I don't know
in a little strange that Tony Stark is
getting this I mean this is a guy that
survived terrorist attacks he had to
replace his heart with this metal light
thingy I know they're trying to add this
layer of realism but it seems a lot but
whatever he's being threatened by the
terrible Mandarin the leader of a
terrorist organization that fouls to
take him down after nearly killing his
bodyguard Tony Stark swears to go after
the Mandarin and does the incredibly
foolish thing of giving him his home
address on public TV for all the world
to see with no plan after that and big
friggin shock the Mandarin comes out to
him and blows the house up this may be
the single dumbest thing a superhero has
ever done there's other good things in
the movie I'm gonna get to it but I just
want to go on record saying that is
probably the stupidest thing in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so Tony is
separated from the world and befriends a
small child who tries to get back on his
feet along the way discoveries are made
secret plans are revealed and of course
even more action and crazy technology
starts to get Gillan
ok so let's once again talk about the
good stuff the action in both Iron Man
movies seemed very minimal and didn't
always play that much to the strengths
of the plot here it's a lot better
there's not only a wide variety of
different action scenes going on but
they're incredibly creative incredibly
funny and don't seem pointless each one
advance
is the story somehow it's also nice to
see that things are kind of stepping up
in size I mean this is a movie that's
coming off of the Avengers so they know
the guys step up their game a bit and
yeah they kind of do there's a lot of
suits all over the place his house is
blowing up he has to travel alone you
have to start from scratch again but it
isn't just a retread of the first movie
either where he's captured by a
terrorist it's a different kind of being
alone even the idea of a child finding a
superhero and trying to help him out
that could have so easily been terrible
but they got a good child actor and they
wrote him pretty decently and they spent
just the right amount of time on him you
think he's gonna follow Ironman
throughout the entire film and get
captured a needs to save him but no he
said the exact amount of time he needs
to be in it but yeah let's get to the
bad stuff besides from like I said the
dumbest move ever done in a Marvel movie
there's this great excitement to see Ben
Kingsley as this terrorist fellow this
Mandarin guy now in the comic he's an
alien and yeah I guess you can't really
do that here or could you I don't know
if the Avengers that kind of got away
with it okay but whatever I didn't read
the comic so I'm not gonna be a purist
however without giving too much away
what'd they do to this character is
gonna piss off a lot of people this is
like the dance in spider-man 3 or what
they did to Deadpool in Wolverine this
is a complete slap in the face to a
character but with that said it is funny
it was a legitimate twist I didn't see
coming yeah it did actually get a few
laughs out but again is that what people
are looking for probably not even though
I didn't read the comic I as well wanted
to see the awesome Ben Kingsley go up
against the awesome Robert Downey jr.
but instead who do we get some asshole
in a suit again oh my god why do these
guys keep popping up nobody cares if he
wrong someone out of a business or
something it's a comic book movie give
us comic book villains every time you
always have in these Iron Man movies
they're either embarrassing out too
early or embarrassing again it's kind of
like watching a Batman movie where he's
fighting the Joker and then halfway
through you find out Oh
the trucker was just a hologram the real
mastermind is this guy who wants to get
you for tax fraud or something who gives
a shit we want to see a comic-book movie
especially after one that celebrated
what a comic book movie it was with the
Avengers so once again we're stuck with
kind of a half-and-half movie on the one
hand the action is good and is visually
interesting and there's some fun ideas
and Tony Stark is still really funny and
they're evolving him a little bit more
but on the other hand some of these
choices are just so bizarre and so
strange and just downright dumb I get
the idea behind Tony Stark you saw this
tortured genius who has a lot of
brilliance but not a lot of wisdom but
come on some of these moves are just
downright stupid for my money I'm still
glad I saw it again is it technically a
good film kind of hard to say I mean you
still get the Iron Man II stuff you want
to see just a bunch of Technology and
action and smartass lines but yeah it is
a little weird that the best of the Iron
Man movies is the original and even that
heck I have a slow silly second half so
yeah I'm glad I saw it I just wanted to
see Iron Man 2 what Iron Man does and I
was fine with it but any diehard fans
are looking for that big Iron Man movie
like the big motto a motto fight and
such are probably gonna be disappointed
when they see what's building up too if
you're just a typical movie goer looking
for a typical action film this one's a
lot of fun but if you're looking for the
evolution of a character or a story you
like this movie we'll probably have to
take a step back
[Music]
so like most people I wanted to see a
Thor movie that took place in his home
turf no fish-out-of-water stuff no
trying to blend in with any funny lines
just Thor being full but after watching
Thor the dark world I might find myself
going back on that remark I know I'm
kind of an outsider on this but I'm
sorry I did not see this as a very good
film it just kind of felt like
in-between pointless exposition on a
character that really could be a lot of
fun to explore in an environment that
could be a lot of fun to explore and
what we do finally explore it it's just
kind of dull looking really this is the
dark world dark moon is fucking boring
really
this is our bad guy who's going to
replace Loki really we have this dumbass
comic relief again okay let me start
from the beginning
some evil jerk who looks like a reject
from the new Star Trek movies is trying
to capture the Infinity stones what are
the Infinity stones about god I don't
wanna explain just powerful things
that's all you need to know and it's up
to Thor to stop him from getting this
stone and of course conquering earth
natalie portman is once again roped in
and sadly she gets way too much screen
time more than actually his other
warrior friends have which is really not
fair I like these warrior friends I
think we need more of them but instead
not only do we get a ton of Natalie
Portman but kat dennings good fucking
god do i hate kat dennings in this movie
I didn't like her in the first one but
at least Thor was on screen we could see
them sort of interact and she said
something stupid whatever if Thor is
there and he's charming and cool here
every time she's on screen she's either
alone or with her scientist friends and
she is so beyond annoying it's like
remember in Star Wars where the comedy
kind of came from the interaction off of
people like the way Luke Skywalker
worked off of Han Solo and he worked off
of Chewie and she worked off of c-3po
and stuff it was the interaction this is
the Jar Jar Binks of the Star Wars
movies all the comedy is just put into
one person and just like Binks she's not
funny help the film opens up with the
scientists running around nude yeah they
create some sort of bullshit explanation
for it but it's entirely pointless you
need it the comedy is beyond desperate
in this every line that is trying to be
funny unless it said from Loki is
painful beyond painful but that's not
the only bad thing about it remember how
grand and huge the worlds looked in the
first Thor here they look nice at least
the palace but aside from that it's just
kind of typical fantasy stuff that you'd
see anywhere again look at this dark
world the movie is named after this and
it is so incredibly not interesting
there's a major character who dies in
this movie I remember thinking to myself
god I should be a lot more invested in
this and I guess I felt bad seeing
Thor's reaction to it but I personally
didn't miss the character that much
because they just didn't make that
person that interesting nobody is that
interesting in this movie the villain
what are you on the scheme seen it a
million times the only thing that's kind
of enjoyable is when Thor has to team up
with Loki again this is as great as it
sounds you like seeing these two
together you like seeing them work off
each other but why they do half way
through the movie they get rid of that
idea and they don't even really start
that until the end of the first third so
that's one third of the movie hell less
than one third if this was the prime
focus maybe it would have been a lot
more fun but nope we gotta make room for
Natalie Portman and kat dennings saying
all their stupid unfunny stuff that
nobody wants to see the movie gives you
no time to really settle down and feel
like you can get attached these
characters which is so weird cuz there's
a whole movie dedicated to them that did
so well at doing that everybody talks
like they just kind of want to get the
story going nobody really relates to
each other again with the exception of
Loki but that's in the movie so little
it can't really save it I guess the only
other thing that's kind of enjoyable is
that the climax does have some creative
ideas it's this device that's kind of
like a portal gun and that you can go
through a hole and come out another area
get zapped you in all sorts of different
places and yeah they do some cool things
with it but again did I really care if
Thor stopped this guy did I really care
if he succeeded as quest I didn't give a
shit
as dumbest setup as the first film was
at least I cared for those people at
least I wanted to see Thor get back home
I don't know this isn't the worst movie
by any means but it's the time that I
felt we could really see Thor being Thor
going out into the field or traveling
through the stars I'm going to the other
world just swinging that hammer doing
the cool stuff once again I could see
those operatic landscapes really taken
advantage of but instead of feeling like
a really grand big comic book it just
kind of feels like a very dull standard
comic book but like I said I know I'm in
a minority and a lot of people really
like this film I don't get it and
there's certainly nothing in it that
straight-up offensive again outside of
maybe kat dennings and we're naked
scientist running around for no reason
but my opinion I'd rather save my money
for Avengers do
[Music]
so I'm just gonna take a wild guess and
say the comments in the last video I did
Thor the dark world are probably not
very positive I'm also gonna take a
guess that people are kind of say well
what did you want what were you actually
looking for Captain America the Winter
Soldier is what I was looking for this
is a sequel that had a previous film
that was good and did a lot more with
its premise than anybody would probably
give him credit for and the sequel dives
even further into it it Tate's the drama
it takes the characters it takes the
story and it ups it to 10 when this film
came out nobody was expecting much yeah
it'd be fun ok let's go and see Captain
America kind of do his thing you know
it's not Avengers but I'm sure I'll be
good everyone was blown away by how much
work and effort went into this one the
development the twists and turns the
action holy smokes this is actually a
great comic book movie Captain America
returns in modern-day Washington DC
where he finds he still having trouble
fitting in but not in the ways that you
think it's not the t he ha ha what's
this thing I don't recognize it's him
trying to deal with the fact that a lot
of people he knew are gone it actually
opens with him visiting his old
girlfriend who's mentally and physically
fading away and you know what it's kind
of a tearjerker this is a woman who was
really likable in the first film has her
own show right now and then suddenly to
see her like this it's sad you really
freaking feel something for this but
that's not where it stops shield it
looks like it's being taken over by the
same people that tried to stop Captain
America in the first film
Nick Fury is dead and the captain is
told not to trust anybody
so he goes rogue he gets a few people to
join them including Black Widow and it's
a chase to not only outrun shield but
also stop that evil organization now
known famously as Hydra while also
trying to figure out the story behind
their newest weapon the Winter Soldier I
think most of the people know what the
story is behind this guy but I'm not
gonna read it ok so this is about as
standard a filler in between plot that
you can get the idea of being chased
down by the people you work for is
recycled the evil organization from the
first film literally recycled a lot of
these characters you've seen before some
from their own TV show yeah
seems about as recycled as you can get
but again in this movie it's not the
subject it's the delivery the atmosphere
and the pacing is so good that whenever
there's a new twist or turn it feels
like a big deal you're surprisingly
really invested in what's going on with
a character that a lot of people found
kind of uninteresting originally because
it knows what to talk about to make him
interesting it talks about how he has a
hard time fitting in it talks about how
he has a hard time figuring out who's on
his side and who isn't it takes the fact
that he is such a Boy Scout to its
advantage because he likes working for
people and he likes doing good the idea
that he hasn't been doing good or is
gonna continue not to do good is
something that would make him feel
really bad and you would feel the
turmoil in that he's fighting for
something you know he would fight for
and hey you would probably fight for two
there's a scene with Garry Shandling
that's actually a creepy scene yeah a
creepy scene with Garry Shandling
somehow this movie made that work and
when you do find out who the Winter
Soldier is it creates a lot of emotional
baggage it's interesting because you
feel their connection and that's what
this movie does it takes all this
standard stuff and you feel for it they
know the right elements to focus on they
know where to put the emphasis it's also
nice to see Black Widow and Captain
America working as a team yeah she still
hasn't gotten her own movie and clearly
she deserves it but if we're not gonna
get it anytime soon the more we can see
her the better and she's great as always
if I could have one nitpick and it
really is an if akai say I could have
used a little bit more with the Winter
Soldier don't get me wrong it's good but
I think because the rest of the film was
so strong and I was so invested I wanted
a little bit more of a rivalry there now
you do care but not as much you do a
rivalry between someone like Batman and
the Joker or Superman and Lex Luthor and
I know those are different kind of
relationships but those also made the
film's feel so much bigger and I wanted
this to feel as big as possible because
hey it kind of got on the right stuff
this could be one of the great big grand
comic-book movies but I think because
the relationship can't be delved with
too much because of all the are things
going on it's
- holds back a little bit from that but
again it's a super big nitpick
everything else in this movie is really
really solid I'm actually amazed at how
good they made this it clearly was just
supposed to be a filler film but they
did their damndest to make it as amazing
as possible this is taking the idea of a
superhero and developing him even more
even one that a lot of people didn't
find that fascinating it took something
standard and it made it intriguing
that's what a good sequel is supposed to
do
good action good story good characters
it hits everything suit up because it's
one hell of a ride
[Music]
it's funny the films I thought would
probably be Marvel's failures Thor and
Captain America everyone kind of knew
we're gonna be okay and they were right
however for me the film I thought would
be okay but everyone thought was gonna
be a failure was guardians of the galaxy
I guess I can kind of see where they're
coming from this is a weird setup we go
from super heroes and super gods to
intergalactic fugitives one being a tree
and one being a raccoon with a machine
gun yeah it's pretty silly but I guess I
know it'd be okay because it kind of
embraced its insanity the marketing said
everything this is not meant to be taken
that seriously it's a raccoon who swears
it's a tree that can only say three
words it's a giant gray guy who
literally doesn't know what sarcasm is
it's the chubby dude from Parks and
Recreation suddenly made to look like a
beefcake this is gonna have a good sense
of humor and it did and people seem to
love it though from the beginning you
might think something else it starts off
with our hero named star-lord watching
his mother die from cancer
she asked him to take his hand he's too
afraid doesn't grab it and she dies he
runs out into the field screaming
because he lost his mother at suddenly
he's abducted by aliens that sounds like
a totally insane opening and it is but
it's a totally insane film years later
he grows up and finds himself living
among the aliens as a bounty hunter
treasure hunter pretty much anything
hunter that's usually illegal but he
gets mixed in with a plot from another
boring bad guy you won't remember God is
Loki really your best villain why is
Marvel so bad at these and he teams up
with a group of Outlaws to try and stop
it
nobody was demanding to see this movie
on the big screen hell nobody even
really knew that much about these
characters but that's sort of what made
it so interesting and new we didn't know
these people we weren't gonna get upset
if they weren't represented a certain
way and nobody really had high standards
because who the hell's reading a comic
about of raccoon with a machine gun and
so the real question is why weren't we
reading a comic about a raccoon with a
machine gun
but nonetheless when the movie came out
everyone went nuts it was one of the
biggest hits of the summer and everybody
adored it and
yeah I like it too did I love it I don't
know if I can say that I like a lot of
the air Marvel movies more but I think
because people's standards were set so
low they were surprised they enjoyed it
as much as they did for me now he
thought was a lot of fun and funny but I
don't know if I see it as quite the big
masterpiece that a lot of other people
are seeing it as the plot once again is
obviously a filler plot it's talking
about the Infinity stones it has a
throwaway villain there's a bunch of
characters that we're gonna see you
later oh hey there's Thanos and he still
does nothing but big one maybe it's like
Winter Soldier and it just does it so
well well it does it okay again this is
supposed to be a comedy so it's a
different kind of movie and it does have
more sentimental scenes but they kinda
come out of nowhere maybe that's the one
issue with the movie is the pacing now
that's too fast or too slow they just
don't always segue into each other very
well there's a really nice scene where
Groot lights up this room with all these
little lights but it's suddenly an
emotional scene in this really big
action-packed moment and it just sir
comes in and leaves too fast there's
another scene where the raccoon is drunk
and suddenly starts a fight and we go
into a little bit of his backstory and
again it just kind of comes out of
nowhere there are my scenes they just
don't always fit in I'm also not sure
why they never made this green lady that
funny everybody has their own little
weird quirk but she's the only one that
doesn't really seem to have anything
that funny about her you could make the
argument that she's the sourpuss who's
grounded but we kind of had this big
great guy for that well maybe she's the
more emotional center well no we kind of
got star-lord for that so yeah even
though she looks kind of cool I didn't
entirely see the purpose over I would
have liked something a little extra to
make her feel like she's more part of
the team but again it's kind of a
nitpick and what's obviously supposed to
be a silly movie and as silly movies go
I don't know what else to really say
about it it's good it has good effects
it has good acting it takes itself
seriously at the right moments and goes
for the all out laughs and other moments
is it clumsy at times yeah look at it's
a raccoon and a tree I'm surprised we
got any of this out of that I'll admit I
don't think I loved it as much as
everyone else did but I thought it
really enjoyable as goofy intergalactic
comedies with a lot of action go this
one's pretty good its creative it's
weird its goofy and it's got a lot of
punches and explosions grab the next
ship to the Stars and see for yourself
[Music]
it's the sequel everyone was waiting for
literally since the end credits of the
last one Avengers the age of Ultron
after one of the most hyped up and
biggest blockbusters of all time came
out everyone was waiting what the second
one was gonna be was gonna be bigger
wasn't gonna be better was it gonna be
funnier in some respects yeah it is all
those things in other respects it's kind
of hard to keep the wow factor going
after such a groundbreaking last one
does that make it bad no does that make
it better than the first one I it's it's
complicated okay let's look at this set
up the Avengers Assemble once again in
order to get Loki's scepter huh they
didn't meet up for all those other times
the world was about to be discounting
book don't think about what Tony Stark's
mind is manipulated by another character
called Scarlet Witch who makes him see a
destroyed future that apparently he's
responsible for like an idiot he reads
it as I didn't do enough so he creates
this computer that's apparently gonna
create peace in our time oh come on he
didn't think that maybe this is what
would cause all those terrible things to
happen because you know the audience is
ten steps ahead of him on that but
whatever he creates this computer
program known as Ultron Ultron of course
was to create peace in his time but in
the way that he knows how by getting rid
of everyone oops forgot to overlook that
glitch
so now Ultron is trying to destroy the
world by making tons of different
versions of himself trying to raise a
giant city as a meteor and smash it into
the world and the Avengers have to
overcome their new mental problems as
well as new physical problems in order
to stop them so yeah pretty weak plot
but again the first film at a pretty
weak plot - and that didn't matter we
just wanted to see The Avengers get
together and fight and work off each
other and say those great one-liners and
in Avengers 2 a we get all that plus
more actually there's a wonderful scene
where they've all been mentally ripped
apart and so they go to this cabin to
try and get away it's easily the best
thing in the film because we haven't
seen anything like that before it felt
like the Avengers were actually evolving
as characters and through a way that
they haven't really done yet so in some
respects it's exactly what we wanted but
in others don't we want to see some
didn't know we wanted like that cabin
scene and don't get me wrong I love that
cabin scene but why is there only one
scene like this in the movie and not
more it's kind of weird because the film
does kind of feel like it's on repeat
here's all these action scenes all these
one-liners and they're good they're well
done there's nothing wrong with them but
there's nothing really new about them
either the wow factor from this is kind
of gone because there aren't really any
New Avengers for them to interact off of
I mean okay there's the Scarlet Witch
and this vast guy and they create this
other one called the vision and at the
end they're indicating that there's even
more being added to the mix but all
these other characters had their own
movies half of these people are being
introduced in this film and the other
ones they were just kind of side
characters we're not exactly excited to
see them here now they're not bad but
they're no Thor Iron Man or Captain
America there's also a totally out of
nowhere romance between Black Widow and
the Hulk and it's good again not bad but
I'm not exactly gonna lose sleep if I
don't see them get together but again it
is evolving the characters to a
different place than when we started I
do feel I found out more about these
people after watching this film than I
did after watching the first Avengers
that's something that was really missing
in the last movie but with everything
else even if it's done good the
investment isn't quite as strong because
we can has seen this stuff before a bad
guy who doesn't see destroying the world
as a bad thing and he tries to make up
some philosophical bullshit about why
it's not people being hypnotized to do
is will the whole world about to be
destroyed in one city and again I hate
talking this way because it's done well
in many respects it's done better than
the first film but it's not evolving
anything that much and don't get me
wrong the audience had a fun time with
this they were laughing they were
applauding they were gasping they're
doing all the things that audience is
supposed to do but when it was all said
and done there wasn't this standing
ovation like there was at the first film
because the first film gave us a lot of
what we never saw and really wanted to
see this gave us what we thought we were
going to see so it's hard to say because
on the one
it is kind of better than the original
we do learn more about these people
there is that wonderful scene at the
house the action is up to there are more
one-liners we do see a lot more The
Avengers together hell there's literally
one scene where they're just hanging out
at a party I could just watch this the
whole entire time they're so interesting
I guess the real problem is it's not an
experience it's a sequel to an
experience trying to clearly be better
and in some cases it is but because
we've already seen a lot of this before
it's not as much blowing us away but
it's still a lot of fun I definitely
recommend it doesn't have stuff that
doesn't make sense are there elements
that are clearly filler for other movies
sure but so did the first one I don't
think this is the groundbreaking sequel
they were hoping for but at the same
time we didn't get a bad film by any
means I think if they did want to blow
us away they would include a lot more
like why are the guardians of the galaxy
in there why wasn't there a Spider Man
cameo you just got him now don't get me
wrong if these are all tie-ins that
maybe I don't understand I mean the fact
that any of this is happening in
Hollywood is pretty amazing so maybe
they couldn't pull it off but that's the
reason people weren't as blown away they
wanted a lot more and instead they got a
little in many respects I do like this
more than the first one hell I probably
prefer watching this one to the first
one but it's not the groundbreaking
follow-up that I think audiences as well
as the studio was hoping for but hell
with what it is and concentrate on what
it is a lot of fun and really enjoyable
if you don't go in overhyped and just
want to see The Avengers being the
Avengers this is definitely a fun one to
check out assemble your team of friends
and take a look
[Music]
following in the style of guardians of
the galaxy that is taking something that
seems totally ridiculous and making it
awesome somehow we have Ant Man again a
seemingly stupid idea that anyone with
half a brain would say would never sell
but you put some talented people some
great effect some creative ideas and you
get a really fun superhero Paul Rudd
plays an ex-con who's just been let out
of prison he wants to be let back in in
his daughter's life but mother sees him
as exactly what is an ex-con he tries to
take the route of getting an honest job
and standing upright but his background
is sadly not giving him enough credit so
through the help of his friends he tries
to take on another con in order to get
his life back on track yeah you figure
out the logic in that but he gets caught
by his scientist played by Michael
Douglas who's frustrated that his
company is working on a weapon that he
thought he got rid of years ago a weapon
that can shrink people down but still
give them unbelievable strength afraid
that this technology has fallen into the
wrong hands
Douglas talks to Rudd about breaking in
and getting the weapon to destroy it
forever using what the weapon of course
a suit that shrinks him down but still
gives him unbelievable powers on top of
that he's also given a device that can
control ants as well
it's about as adorably silly as it
sounds with the help of Douglass's
daughter played by even to lean Lily
it's a heist movie of both the largest
and smallest of caliber the reaction to
this movie when it came out was pretty
much the same everyone said it was good
not great but good it's a movie that
we've seen a million times a heist film
all the superhero stuff but it's done
creatively and uniquely enough that
people seem to like it fine I think I
liked it a little bit more than everyone
else I agree with what they're saying
that this has been done a million times
and we see the superhero stuff all
around but I feel like there's more
effort that was put into these
characters then you see a lot of times
in these kind of stories this is a
really good cast
they help breathe new life into a lot of
these cliches that we've seen over and
over but they deliver it in their own
unique and likable way even though I've
heard this story about how Douglass
doesn't want to lose his daughter and
how Paul Rudd realizes that family is
the most important and all this stuff
something about the way they say it and
the way they do it
it feels like you're hearing it for the
first time I really appreciate actors
that can pull that off but on top of
that they take advantage of this
situation they make it fun they make it
visually interesting and you really feel
the size of this person the idea of
being shrunken down has been done a
million times and honestly when I heard
they were making a movie out of this I
was thinking oh god another Honey I
Shrunk the kids this is so done to death
but again they add new elements on top
of it the fact that is a supersuit the
fact that he can get bigger and smaller
whenever he wants the fact that they can
make anything they want bigger or
smaller they make keychains toys all
sorts of various things gigantic and
it's great it's wonderful to see the
climax actually takes place onto Thomas
the Tank Engine Railroad set that's both
really funny and really action-packed at
the same time again it's taking kind of
a standard idea and it's adding a new
spin to it
I love how Marvel can do that it feels
like no matter what subject matter
they're doing or talking about they can
add something that's unique to it
whether it be a writer or a style of
acting or effects they always add that
element of cool so I like this movie
actually even more than most people like
it is it an action classic
no and it's no kind of masterpiece but I
was invested from beginning to end and I
want to know what's gonna happen in the
sequels
the idea of this guy joining the
Avengers sounds like a really good idea
I love to see how he interacts with
everybody he'll I want to see how all
these characters interact with the
Avengers
maybe that's how we judge a really good
movie that when it's done I don't want
to be done with it I want to see even
more with it I want to see more explored
I want to see more of these characters I
want to see more of their interactions I
want to see more things get bigger and
smaller I want to see more of those
creative action sequences so I
definitely had a lot of fun with it
shrink yourself down and experience it
for yourself
[Music]
it's arguably the most popular film of
several past generations Star Wars what
can you say about franchise as huge as
this well I could say I was introduced
to it by the Ewoks yep
the Ewoks cartoon is what got me into
watching these movies actually even
that's not even true the Ewoks cartoon
got me to watching the Ewoks movies that
went to TV then that got me into
watching the actual movies the reason I
bring this up is that I didn't really
have much hype for it nobody said this
is a cinematic masterpiece it's one of
the greatest movies ever made it's
phenomenal granted I did see images from
it all over the place but for the most
part I discovered it myself and like a
lot of people I not only greatly enjoyed
it but found great value in just how
many levels that entertained on kids
could watch it adults could watch it you
could tune in for the action or read
into the symbols admire how new it is
but also cheerfully paying homage to
laugh and cheer while also analyzing
what a very detailed mythos it is the
story as I am assuming most of you know
is about an evil empire that's taken
over the galaxy and wants to finish off
the last of the rebellion a rebel spy
named Princess Leia hype the plans to
destroy their newest weapon called the
Death Star with two droids named r2d2
and c3po they come across a farm boy
named Luke and a magical hermit named
obi-wan they realize they have to get
these plans to the rebels so they come
across a pilot named Han Solo and
Chewbacca on their way they get snagged
by the evil empire led by the sinister
Darth Vader and end up trying to rescue
the princess while also destroying the
evil weapon before it destroys them okay
so what can I say about this film that
everybody hasn't said before well for
one it's not perfect which I know
doesn't sound shocking nowadays but for
time before the Internet how is
something you almost never said
everybody loves Star Wars and thought
frame-by-frame was just the ultimate
masterwork but as much as I love it
you've gotta admit some of its pretty
corny actually a lot of it but in the
best way the acting at times can be a
little hokey remember Princess Leia's
we're British accent for Luke's ear
grading lis whiny voice or solos
constant complaining yeah watch it again
and tell me you don't pick up on some of
this on top of that some of the dialogue
can be
like when leia tells the villains she
should have noticed their foul stench
when she was brought on board
um snap there's also a billion plot
threads that don't make sense but I kind
of let those go because it's fantasy and
that's never what the focus of fantasy
really is the magic doesn't lie in the
details but in how many different ways
it can speak to you as well as several
generations and that's what Star Wars
does really well as cliched and hokey
some of these characters can be we all
relate to them the wide-eyed Luke
Skywalker the cynical Han Solo the wise
master teacher the villain with a past
it really is clever and how much it
takes from certain stories from fairy
tales to folklore to Kurosawa to Stanley
Kubrick and even Flash Gordon in fact a
lot from Flash Gordon throwing the
special effects of 2001 but mixed with
the pacing of say uh James Bond movie at
the time and you have something that was
very unique it explains all the areas
you want to know about and keeps vague
the areas you don't want to know about
the force is a perfect example of that
it's the magic energy that flows through
us all that can help people if they know
how to use it that can be anything it
can be religion it can be how is Amit
can be the power of God it can be the
power of the mind there's so many ways
you can interpret it the beauty of the
film is in its simplicity but with that
said there is a lot of detail in the
techniques the effects at the time were
groundbreaking and done for not a very
big budget it just took a lot of time
energy and devotion as well as pretty
good actors interacting off of it for as
simple as these archetypes are and yeah
sometimes as awkward as they can be
you still connect with them very quickly
we don't know much about Darth Vader yet
but by God James Earl Jones voice gives
him such a history you can tell this is
a guy who means business because he's
been through a lot and all of that just
comes through the voice and the
seriousness that everybody takes this
dialogue that a lot of other people will
kind of see a silly
as a surprising credibility to this
world a world that creates an
environment that both seems very simple
but somehow complex at the same time
sure it's silly but it's endearing and
puts a lot of thought in the areas that
you want to put a lot of thought into as
a lot of good myths do is it one of the
great myths I don't know if I can go
that
are still say probably check out a lot
of traditional ones to get an idea of
what great storytelling is but for the
film industry at the time and even you
could kind of argue today you don't
really see that many myths at least not
new ones and that one that captures so
many of the important elements so
creatively and with such fun yeah I know
I guess I'm saying what everybody says
about this movie but I can't help it
it's good
I really enjoyed as a kid and I really
enjoy it now okay I can't quite join the
group and say it's one of the greatest
things I've ever seen but it has
definitely left an impact on me and for
the right reasons for me it was a
gateway to other myths an introduction
to simple storytelling that can lead to
vast worlds and I appreciate it greatly
for that I see its flaws but the stuff
that's good it's just too clever to
overlook I don't know if it's the stroke
of a creative artist or a jumbled mess
that accidentally turned out something
great but it's a lot of fun to both
watch and analyze I can see why they
show it in film classes and analyze it
here and there is it overplayed sure do
we praise it too much probably but it's
a great starting point for opening up to
more great stories so grab your
lightsaber get into your x-wing and may
the force be with
[Music]
how do you top one of the
highest-grossing most seen movies of all
time you give it a sequel that doesn't
do the exact same thing over but instead
continues the story and in a dark dark
way the Empire Strikes Back is often
said to be the best of the Star Wars
trilogy or really any of the Star Wars
films and yeah they're pretty much right
we open once again with the Empire
seeking out the rebels let again by
Darth Vader as Luke gets a message from
a deceased obi-wan that he is to seek
out Yoda the Jedi Master that taught him
after being attacked by the Empire
Luke's separates from Han and Leia in
order to find this master Jedi and learn
the ways of the force while learning
these new ways the rest of the gang
takes shelter in Cloud City a place
ruled by Lando Calrissian but little
does everybody know that the Empire has
an evil trap for all of them especially
for Luke who Vader has a keen interest
in it's so refreshing that the sequel to
one of the highest-grossing films of all
time is actually doing something a
little different not just different but
taking chances the pacing is slower the
imagery is darker it wasn't telling the
story like it was a sequel it was
telling it like it was the second part
in fact this was the first time on the
big screen they actually put episode 5
on there with Lucas revealing this is
now a six-part movie series why start at
number 4 who knows but people were
enjoying it so much
bading can they just figure he could do
no wrong which hey now I get to that
later everybody likes this movie for
different reasons well actually that's
not true they all like we're the same
reason it's darker
there's more drama leaves you on a
cliffhanger it's taking this
happy-go-lucky adventure that we have
with the first one and making it much
more gritty me personally I like it
because it took the very basic good
versus evil story it started to gray it
out a little bit I think most people
know the big surprise in this film but
I'm not gonna give it away in case you
don't I will say when it was revealed I
didn't see a coming but my mind wasn't
quite blown like everyone else actually
I thought to myself yeah that sounds
about right that solid line of good
versus evil black versus white was
suddenly being blurred and it was
actually very welcoming as much as we
love to say the dark side and the light
side this suddenly made it a little bit
more interest
it didn't always have to be the cowboy
with the black hat and the cowboy with
the white hat you could get a little bit
more three-dimensional wizard and
speaking of which the movie really does
seem more three-dimensional a lot of it
is spending time diving inward we have a
romance blooming with Han and Leia we
have Luke trying to figure out how to
use the force there's a lot more symbols
and foreshadowing in it in one a
direction I think a lot of kids didn't
see coming and he'll even probably a lot
of adults didn't see coming but that's
great because it just got us more
invested the effects once again for the
time are still pretty damn incredible
the puppet work on Yoda even though yeah
he does look like a muppet still feels
very much alive the eyes the expression
the moving of the wrinkles on his brow
it's the same as watching Kermit the
Frog you know he's not real but he feels
real he would later be replaced with a
CG Yoda and the prequels and even when
he looked the most realistic you never
got the impression he was really there
you got the impression obi-wan was
looking at nothing here you never feel
like Luke's just talking to a guy
holding a puppet you feel like he's
talking to Yoda and it's not just the
use of a great practical effect it's the
use of great writing and acting all of
it plays a part I also love how much
more menacing they make the Empire in
this not that they were not threatening
in the original but good God Vader just
went from this guy who sort of stood in
the corner to this monstrous beast
whenever he comes out with that
lightsaber you feel the intimidation you
feel like you're gonna lose to this guy
this is when he suddenly went from just
being a cool bad guy to one of the
greatest villains ever he could lunge at
you and rip you apart but he could also
stand perfectly still and destroy you he
can be very patient and intelligent but
he can also be stubborn killing anyone
he just doesn't like it's a brilliant
depiction of someone you love to be
afraid of the movie also goes much more
into the philosophy of the force but
again not too much it talks about what
it is but not how it is it talks about
the experience but not why you're
experiencing it about feeling it but not
touching it and again it's not all done
in dialogue there's a great scene where
Luke just goes into this area and the
swamp and comes across Vader we know
it's not really him it can't really be
him and yet the fight takes place and he
sees
own face inside the mask those are the
exact right choices that have you say oh
my god
what does that mean what can it mean it
gives you just the right tools to build
your own conclusion again as good
storytelling should so yeah like
everyone else it's my favorite out of
the Star Wars films are still details
that don't make sense sure but it's the
same as the first one you overlook it
cuz the rest is just so good and you
know that's not the focus the focus is
to be sucked into this world and it's
characters almost the people who watch
it honor it's more intense more
suspenseful poor visual more
philosophical more dramatic more of what
you come to love the force is strong
with this one
[Music]
it's the final in the now very poorly
named Star Wars trilogy Return of the
Jedi everyone says this is the least of
the original three Star Wars films not
bad just not as good as the other two
and honestly I think it gets a little
bit of a bum rap not to say the
criticisms aren't right it's just the
stuff that's good in it I think is a lot
better than some of the stuff in the
other films but does that make it better
than the other two well let's take a
look Han Solo is kept captive by the
evil gangster Jabba the Hutt Luke Leia
and Lando all try to sneak in to break
him out but they get caught themselves
after several fight sequences and
battling a bunch of monsters they
eventually escape and make it back to
the rebellion where they find out the
Empire is once again building another
Death Star only this time the leader of
the Empire the Emperor will be on there
for them to take it down so the team
tries to take down the shield generator
it's on a nearby moon while the rest of
the fighters try to fly in to blow it up
the team on the moon comes across
inhabitants called Ewoks while Luke
separates from the team to confront the
Emperor and Darth Vader himself and the
rebels take down the evil empire once
and for all and while Luke ultimately
find himself turning to the light side
or the dark side
a fitting set up for a finale but the
biggest problem everybody has that I
have to admit I have too is that there's
way too many detours the opening
sequence with Jabba the Hutt and
breaking Han Solo out it goes on forever
there's a moment you can end up where
Luke destroys this big monster but no
they had to drag them to another monster
for him to destroy truth be told you
could cut everything having to do with
Jabba out of these movies and you would
miss nothing think about it you could
have Han Solo captured by anybody help
you don't even really need to get rid of
him that's just sort of leaving it open
for a cliffhanger
he could have been with the team he
didn't have to be sent away honestly the
Ewoks play a bigger part than the Jabba
the Hutt scenes I know that sounds crazy
but really think about it the Ewoks help
take down the Empire they play a part
they serve the story and it also makes a
well-intended if not immaturely done
message of nature versus technology
which is in a lot of stories and myths
so why do we put up with those Java
seems so
well to put simply javis a cool
character he's this big fat slug that
just does whatever he wants it's kind of
the American dream he's a gangster and
he gets away with it so why doesn't many
people hate the Ewoks because one we
already saw a ton of puppets and we're
getting sick of them second their little
teddy bears and after the last film
where everything was so dark and gritty
what we suddenly got a bunch of little
teddy bears this is feeling more like a
toy commercial in my honest opinion if
you want to fix this Jabba should have
been on the moon cut out the opening
save him until halfway have him capture
solo wanting his money back but then
when he finds out the Empire is in his
territory then he decides to fight him
off and help the rebellion how much more
fitting with that offend Jabba would
have been built the bad guy and the good
guy at the same time and he would have
had a purpose and oh my god would it be
so cool if you saw Jabba's people
attacking those stormtroopers instead of
he wants also throw in a pointless
motorcycle style chase and all too
similar retread of the destroying the
Death Star in the first film and little
teddy bears throwing rocks and yeah you
can see how a lot of people would see
this as the lesser of the films but with
that said not only are these some of the
best effects that ever came out of the
movies but it has some of the most
dramatic moments the scenes where Luke
is confronting Vader and the Emperor are
some of the best in any of the movies
the guy they got to play the Emperor is
perfect he's old and frail but by god he
has such presence and this deep
crackling voice with these yellow eyes
it's almost something out of the
Exorcist at times his acting can be a
little goofy but it's goofy in just the
right way he's taking a risk that you're
in such a dark uncomfortable mood that
you're just going to accept that this is
creepy and for the most part it works
the whole atmosphere is just so dark and
so brooding and so shadowy you just feel
like you've descended into hell
the minute Luke walks is their prisoner
the Emperor just gets rid of the
handcuffs like yeah we know there's
nothing you can do here and the longer
it goes the more we dive deeper and
deeper into the darker side of Luke's
anger of Luke's
and the visuals all support it the
pacing supports it too there's a fight
going on but it's also very
psychological the music the atmosphere
the acting the dialogue everything it's
perfect it's about as pitch perfect a
scene you can get in any Star Wars film
but does that make up for the other
little mistakes in the film
probably not but like I said before even
though a lot of it doesn't always
connect it cool the scenes with job are
cool and yeah I'll even say the Ewoks
are not as bad as everybody says they
are
they let this am okay jokes and I like
the idea of wood trampling steel by the
end when everything wrapped up it just
kind of felt right when you see the
final scene in the Ewok village you just
kind of go yeah you know what this is a
good place to stop everybody seems happy
everybody seems in the right place where
their flaws sure but just like there
were flaws in the other films too I
guess I just don't get what everybody
says this is the light-hearted one when
there were such dark and gritty scenes
in it some of them the best out of any
of the movies so yeah is the first film
technically told better yes but I still
stand by the third has some of the best
moments out of many of them and like I
said it's just a good ending not the
best but still pre-dam impressive and
for a while this is all Star Wars fans
thought they would ever get out of this
but little did they know that so much
more good and bad was awaiting them in
the future
[Music]
what can I say about the most despised
movie prequel in cinema history well I
can say this who has two thumbs and
totally saw it coming
this guy that's right I've been waiting
years for these bragging rights and now
it's finally come I knew from the first
trailer that this was gonna be a bad
movie it just can't keep down to logical
deduction Lucas only directed one Star
Wars Vil and as impressive as it was it
had a lot of problems the writing was
hokey the acting was stilted and there's
a lot of things that didn't always make
sense but he had a lot of people to give
him advice and limitations so it still
turned out a good product then years
later after barely directing a thing
this guy is suddenly supposed to direct
a masterpiece
though in all fairness even I couldn't
guess it'd be this bad it starts off as
obi-wan and his master are trying to
figure out some sort of political
taxation Federation stuff that yeah like
you I can't figure out either they tried
to help the newly-elected child Queen
Amidala which you don't elect Queens and
queens can't be children but whatevs
and along the way they come across the
death of comedy Jar Jar Binks and the
death of acting Anakin Skywalker Anakin
it turns out as a virgin birth yeah
can't get any more obvious than that and
according to a blood test apparently the
force is very strong with him oh the
amount of people this pissed off Oh
we'll get to that later they by Anakin
from one stereotype to deliver him to
two other stereotypes we're in cahoots
with a senator named Palpatine who is
secretly the Emperor who wants to get
the Queen to sign the treaty because
political stuff we get sword fights
gunfight space battles and through all
of it I have no idea what they're
fighting for but who cares right in the
original is just an evil empire we
didn't really know their politics they
were just kind of evil so maybe we can
just do the same thing here right well
that would work if the characters were
the least bit interesting and by God are
they not my complaints are your
complaints the acting is so wooden the
writing so fifth-grade the effects way
too computer-generated the comedy way
too kinder
and the stereotypes way too offensive
yeah what else can I say about this that
every other person on the planet hasn't
said well I guess I'll try to defend it
a touch as everybody acts like this is
the worst thing ever made and it's not
it's just a bad movie coming off the
heels of some of the most popular films
ever made as tiring as the constant CG
gets in this there are a lot of very
neat landscapes the worlds are very
creative and very beautiful to look at
the sword fights got a lot better to
remember when Darth Vader and obi-wan
were just kind of tapping those light
sticks together well now this is a
straight-on battle and it looks amazing
it's still impressive even years later
now where do you see it as a good thing
or a bad thing there is something
interesting watching a guy's dream
suddenly come to life with nobody
getting in the way it's a fully realized
vision with no filters whatsoever and as
someone that loves film and artists it's
interesting to see it just so happens
it's not very good but it's still
interesting was this always planned from
the beginning probably not but it's also
kind of neat to see the changes he'd
want to make and yeah what happens when
a filmmaker stays away from his craft so
long I can't even make a small argument
for the midi-chlorians it's been proven
that a lot of people that seem to have a
spiritual essence or a lot of energy the
water in their blood is affected so in a
very slim way you could kind of make the
argument that this is credible and
doesn't get in the way of the
philosophical and religious aspects but
even I admit it's very very slim I'm
just trying to offer an interesting
point of view but yeah like everyone I
thought this was a journalist the
story's too complicated for kids to
follow and the dialogue is too childish
for adults to follow so unlike the
original three where it's book two both
this one speaks to neither I'm hearing
more and more that there are a lot of
kids that grew up with this because hey
they like Jar Jar they like poop jokes
and they like a lot of the visuals which
is interesting when you watch them grow
up and realize that the original three
films were much better than this
honestly the most entertaining thing
about this film is the fan reaction the
fact that people waited days in line and
then were in such denial when they found
out it was bad they didn't even admit it
was bad they tried
argan with themselves and be convinced
that it was actually good but over time
nobody could defend the poop jokes
nobody could defend the racial
stereotypes as much as critics at the
time actually tried to say this was a
good movie yeah look up the reviews at
the time they tried to defend it it
showed in full view the power of hype
and how long it took for so many people
to admit the emperor has no clothes
honestly in many respects it's kind of
an important movie for that it shows
that artists are flawed and there is no
perfect project help even the original
Star Wars had a lot of stilted acting
and hokey dialogue for a lot of fans
this was the bursting of the bubble the
ending of the fairy tale the having to
face real life but there's advantages to
that too it tells people that hey you
don't have to be perfect to make good
stuff you can learn you can change
things you can make stuff better even
your heroes aren't always your heroes
and that's okay you can be inspired to
do better work if you're one of those
people that claim Lucas killed your
childhood you've never had a childhood
to begin with or you're constantly
trying to stay in it and reject your
grown-up world bottom line he got his
vision made and it sucked but at least
he got it made exactly how he wanted it
it still did well the box office so you
can't claim as a waste of money but yeah
after years of spin-off books and
spin-off games and so much those be done
with the Star Wars universe that Lucas
had little involvement with did I expect
a lot more oh yeah but it's still such
an interesting turn out in how strange
and awful it is that it's kind of
something to analyze we'll never know
was it just too many Yes Men or was he
away from filming too long or was he
never really that talented to begin with
it was just other people that made it
work it's one of the great mysteries
that's fun to speculate and if you like
it great I wish I could have such an
innocent mind not to see all these
offensive stereotypes I'm sure he
thought he was doing some sort of clever
commentary but if you don't see how this
movie can piss off a lot of people enjoy
it
you're definitely part of a rare
minority and don't let anyone take that
away from you but for me and a lot of
other people it's as if the voices of
millions of people cried out in terror
and were suddenly never give
their money back
[Music]
so despite what you may think even
though I really didn't like phantom
menace Attack of the Clones
in my opinion is the worst why because
not only was so little learned from the
mistakes of the first film okay there's
a lot less jargon but this one is just
straight-out boring it is dull it's not
very interesting to look at it's not
very interesting to listen to the
stilted acting is still there the bad
writing is still there there's tons of
things in the plot that don't add up
which would matter if I gave a shit at
all what was going on and I don't even
Phantom Menace had the avenge that it
was spectacular a bad bad on such a big
level this one is just a boring me
Anakin Skywalker has grown up and
apparently has yet to develop a
personality as he apparently comes
across Amidala who is now not queen
another election I guess but
nevertheless he's assigned to protect
her after a few assassination attempts
the two eventually end up falling in
love but this is a big no-no as
apparently Jedi's can't fall in love
well that sucks not sure why that is but
whatever while their incredible
chemistry is being formed Senator
Palpatine makes a decision to form a
clone army these will eventually become
the stormtroopers that have different
voices in the later films that I think
they're talking about actually replacing
with Australian voices nevermind and
they're gonna take out more of that
political nonsense you couldn't follow
in the first movie except this time
Christopher Lee is in it well that's
cool I like Christopher Lee but what's
he doing there what's his evil plan more
political talk that you can't follow and
honestly that's about it they try to
fill up all these other things going on
but it's not interesting and since you
can't really follow the political talks
or the war talks or anything like that I
don't really know what it ties in to
what's supposed to be important we get a
little bit of Anakin being separated
from his mother but he just kind of says
he's upset and angry and that's about it
there's not any more diving into it the
romance is kind of similar to they just
kind of say they're in love over and
over and find really corny ways of
saying it and that's it you never feel
any chemistry out of them because the
acting is so stilted
at this point out starting to realize it
wasn't the actors being chosen that was
the problem now don't get me wrong some
of them can actually do okay
when McGregor is actually a pretty good
replacement for obi-wan Christopher Lee
is always a lot of fun and of course
Palpatine is always great actually just
realizing it's all the Brits the British
people are the only ones that give great
performances in these movies even in the
first Star Wars films Ford and Hamill
are a little whiny but with the
exception of James Earl Jones it's all
the British people that add the
credibility to the movie
maybe that's why Carrie Fisher tried to
do the British accent but regardless
what I'm getting to is that unless you
have a really really good actor it's
hard to make this dialogue sound natural
and you have to put a lot of trust in
your director that what you're doing
sounds and looks good and I think we've
established that Lucas has been out of
touch with being a good director for a
while so yeah I can't really blame the
actors for how terrible they're reading
these lines they're hard lines to read
and if someone is giving you the
direction to make it sound more and more
bland you're gonna just do it one of the
only things people really remember out
of this film is the lightsaber fight
with Yoda people either seem to love or
hate this and yeah and somewhere in
between I understand both sides of the
argument on the one hand yeah it is kind
of neat to see Yoda with a lightsaber
it's cool to see him jump around and
shows that such a little person can
still cause a lot of damage but like the
other half of people I kind of like the
fact that all you had to do was wave a
hand and a spaceship could fly by like
he was that powerful he had to do was
just point a finger he was bad in touch
with the force I don't know I'm just
glad it was something I didn't really
see before and it was kind of neat to
see there'll be a kind of goofy but
trust me that's nothing compared to the
other goofy scenes in this like a 50s
diner in a galaxy far far away yeah this
isn't like the cantina Mos Eisley where
it's like oh it kind of looks like a bar
but it's still kind of its own thing no
this is just a diner designed a little
differently did Star Wars have the 50s
come on there still has to be something
otherworldly about it not just Oh take a
diner waitress and make her a robot boom
and then the grand scheme of things my
brother brought up a really good point
he said what is the point of this film
and the last one
after seeing Revenge of the Sith I
realized there really isn't any you
could just watch Revenge of the Sith and
you can figure out everything that
Anakin was in love that he was emotional
they wasn't ready to become a Jedi
everything you needed to know wasn't
that one these two films were completely
pointless no characters develop the
political talks are impossible to follow
and not very interesting there is no
real insight into anything and between
the two of them this one seems the most
pointless
it's forgettable it's dull it's not even
that creative you can't even really
enjoy it for how bad it is well okay
some lines but it's still mostly just a
drag oh yeah that line makes it in the
movie too from c-3po oh it's so stupid
anyway if you want to rip it apart a nip
ticket there's more than enough material
but in my opinion if he came and say
it's so bad it's good this is the Star
Wars movie you can easily skip
[Music]
so out of all the Star Wars prequels
that came out this was the one that felt
the closest like a Star Wars movie it
opens with star destroyers and a space
battle and lightsabers and going in and
rescuing people and running through the
ship and shooting lasers and yeah this
is Star Wars and it's easy to follow
once again the focus is on the
simplicity of the character you
understand why Anakin is angry you
understand what he's going through now
does that make up for everything
no it's still by definition a pretty bad
movie but this is the first time
watching or I said you know what I'm
glad I saw a Star Wars prequel
there's just enough good things and
inside and visuals that maybe glad that
I paid the money to go see it it's a few
years later and Anakin finds out that
Amidala is pregnant this is already big
trouble that's gonna be even bigger
trouble when he has a vision showing
that she's probably gonna die at
childbirth but he's becoming more chummy
chummy with Palpatine and tells him that
the ways of the dark side can actually
find a way to save her life
slowly but surely Anakin is being won
over to that side as Obi one goes to do
more of that political sword fighting
nonsense that's in the other films but
it's not as focused on here the focus is
what it should be on Anakin and I think
most people know what's gonna happen
he's gonna become Darth Vader things are
gonna go wrong there's gonna be a big
separation between him and obi-wan but
this is the first time it plays how
closer to how you may think it's
supposed to play out
there's betrayal there's manipulation
there's big sword fights there's
explosions there's student against
teacher the ultimate failure and yet
there's still so many other dumb seems
like when Anakin does turn as everybody
says it's way too fast and out of
nowhere it's one thing to say you all
learn the dark side to save your loved
one but to kill so many people to
completely switch sides and kill young
ones all younglings or whatever the hell
they're called it's completely out of
nowhere and the acting is not strong
enough
but out of all of them this is probably
the most visual story tale you can watch
this on mute on al I almost recommend it
and still get an idea of what's going on
it felt more like we're in the Star Wars
universe like it has a history the scene
at the Opera where he's giving the
backstory and the mythos that's one of
the best moments I've seen in any Star
Wars movie and everybody whether they're
doing a good job acting or not look the
part and it can looks amazing this is
what you would imagine a young angry
Darth Vader would look like but yes like
I said before I make fun of the moments
you make fun of too
Darth Vader shouting no the stupid
romantic dialogue to feel so forced the
plot threads that don't add up
I make fun of it all too but at the very
least I finally got something that felt
a little closer to what these prequels
was supposed to be it is dark it is
brooding it is gritty it has big battles
and manipulation that you can actually
follow this time truth be told it's a
movie I don't mind popping in every once
in a while do I laugh at the stupid
scene sure and do I still point out all
the things that don't make sense
yeah but the fight scenes and the
cinematography and the way it visually
tells it's touring is really really
interesting by no means perfect I don't
even really think you can say it's good
but it has good things in it some of
them the best out of any of the Star
Wars movies and it's hard for me not to
recommend that the first one's
interesting to watch to see just how bad
it can be but you don't really need to
see it in order to figure out what's
going on here and the second one is a
complete forgettable mess this is the
first one where I felt like I actually
learned a little something or at least
what the intention was I didn't feel the
emotions but I felt the idea behind the
emotions if that makes sense it's a
tough call if you want to see the movie
to know a little bit more about what was
supposed to be going on it's interesting
but if you want an actual good movie I
still can't say that it is but at least
it was finally feeling like Star Wars
and looking like Star Wars Eve if we had
to put up with a lot of dumb bullshit
I think you can figure out if this is
something you would benefit from or if
it would just piss you off more and for
a while it seemed like this was the end
of the Star Wars movies but literally
and figuratively a new hope seemed to be
in the future
[Music]
it's time to talk about those
controversial special editions and when
I say controversial I mean geeks
complaining about stuff that's clearly
not but more geeks is what we do in the
mid 90s George Lucas re-released the
Star Wars films on the big screen which
was a big deal a lot of us never saw it
on the big screen so this was something
really wonderful to see and on top of
that he updated a lot of the effects
added new scenes and gave it a total
digital clean up people freed they
couldn't stand the idea that he went and
changed up something that was so perfect
how dare you touch even one frame of
this everything about it is absolutely
magnificent how dare you my take on it I
should we think it's kind of cool it's
kind of nice to see a little bit of an
update it was also a clever way to get
new and younger audiences into the seats
yeah I don't like it either but you know
there's a lot of younger people out
there they say oh the effects they look
fake now so I don't like it and on top
of that Lucas said this was the version
he always wanted to see this is a world
where there was no limitation he could
show much more of Cloud City he could
show much more of Moss Eisley he could
have a bigger dance number in Jabba's
palace and some of these really work and
some of them really don't for example
when you first see Mos Eisley it's need
to get a lot more different angles and
see a lot more creatures running around
but then they literally put creatures in
front of the camera there's a robots
going by and these giant dinosaur things
you literally can't see what's going on
why would you do that you're missing an
important scene the first using of the
force in the entire thing but it's hard
to make out because there's this
dinosaurs but in the way it's totally
nuts but then some things are really
neat to see like they shot a scene of
Jabba talking to Han Solo in the first
film that was later replaced with the
Greedo scene because they felt the
technology wasn't able to do it yet well
now it Ken is sort of the first time we
saw him was neat but he did look kind of
fake and suddenly he had these perfect
lip movements well that's weird cuz it
returned the Jedi it's still a puppet
with his mouth moving up and down but
now he can form perfect syllables they
would later do another special edition
where they've replaced him again this
time with the mouth moving up and down
but he looked even worse he still didn't
look like he was there he looks so
incredibly fake and on top of that the
scene is pointless because they leave
the Greedo scene still in there so
Jabba's just repeating what we already
heard and with that said yeah let's talk
about the whole Han shot first thing in
the original version Greedo has a gun at
Han Solo and Han Solo shoots him to get
out of it well Lucas didn't like that so
he had it where grito shoots first and
then Han Solo shoots back now taking out
the fact that this is a horrible looking
effect it literally looks like they just
Photoshop Harrison Ford's head over a
little
everyone once again went nuts that's not
how it's supposed to go han Solo
supposed to shoot first it's a total
betrayal of his character and everything
that Han Solo is it's destroyed because
of this one scene okay it's stupid and
not needed but it's literally one second
people are still bitching and moaning
about this dumb ass scene and it's
ridiculous that like somebody told him
that Luke Skywalker was a Jawa or
something it's not that big a deal it's
a different take on an already popular
scene need it's cool to see a new point
of view why the hell is this worth going
apeshit over yeah don't worry soon the
prequels will come and suddenly you'll
have nothing to complain about this will
still be the most offensive thing you
will ever see in a Star Wars film and
Empire Strikes Back the changes are a
little bit more minimal but look nice
cloud city for example you can see a lot
more of and they even explain some
things that were a little confusing in
the original like when Lando Calrissian
gets on this little microphone and says
everybody evacuate the city
but Waymon where was that going to you
never see who's hearing it you just kind
of assume it's that one building in the
special edition you see it's a speaker
that reaches out to the entire city but
then again does he just have a little
microphone like that anywhere couldn't
anyone get on that microphone and
details details you also see a lot more
of the monster that attacks Luke in the
opening and you see how the hell Vader
got from Cloud City to the Star
Destroyer so quickly
yeah that always bothered me in the
original it's like he was in one
location then suddenly he's in another
here we actually see him take the ship
and go back it's a little detail that's
nice to have
Jedi most of the changes are good too
but there's still a couple of things
they're a little too crazy the dance
sequence in Jabba's palace for example
goes from this muddy dark dirty plays to
this big musical number and there's a
lot of moving and dancing and it's just
a little too childish for me on top of
the fact that again the CG monsters
never really look like they're there but
whatever again it's neat to kind of see
a new point of view we also see a plan
at the end that we never saw in any of
the other versions but would later be in
the prequels yeah remember that planet
that's entirely a city you see it here
and on top of that if you look closely
you see a statue of the Emperor falling
over that's actually a nice little
detail so when they first came out I
didn't mind the special editions and I
still don't it's neat to see a brand new
angle on a lot of this and it's cool
then artists gets to go back revisit his
work and touch it up a bit
honestly I'm not even against the idea
of constantly going back and changing
things up yeah it's a little weird you
should probably leave good enough alone
but at the same time effects do keep
changing and they do keep updating I
can't like the idea of comparing
different special editions and seeing
which effects hold up better how far
we're coming or how backwards weren't
going some of these CG effects look so
much better but then some of the
practical effects looked a lot better I
kind of like comparing and contrasting
so the idea of constantly going in and
updating it I don't mind what I do mind
is that we can't see the original that's
where I think people can get
legitimately upset we should be allowed
to compare and contrast why are we just
ignoring history if Abraham Lincoln
released another version of the
Gettysburg Address and said this is what
I really wanted to say that'd be mean I
would love to see that but if you went
back and said no this is what I said and
what you heard is completely false and
doesn't exist I'm gonna erase it that
would be stupid and four years Lucas
never allowed the original versions to
be see after the VHS of the special
editions came out that was then the only
version you could get when it went to
DVD it was the special edition again
except there were even more changes in
it yeah
now Hayden Christensen is at the end
instead of Luke's father well
a minute why isn't that it McGregor is
ob1 then why isn't that younger Yoda I
get the idea of wanting to book in the
prequels and the other films but this
makes no sense but again the biggest
problem is we weren't allowed to see the
original on blu-ray or DVD or any of
that
it's like Lucas was ashamed of the
effects that they weren't up to where
they could be at the time but they were
groundbreaking they were amazing they're
still impressive to look at sure they're
a little bit more fake now but again
it's neat to see the evolution of a
project in my opinion you can make as
many changes as you want as many
versions as you want I think it's a lot
of fun to look and compare them but if
you don't have the original you can't
see what got everybody interested in
this to begin with you're denying newer
generations what the older generation
saw and got sucked into however I do
hear that the original versions are
being released now if they haven't been
already now that it's out of George
Lucas's hands this is definitely a good
thing as we deserve to see more than the
VHS version of the original films so on
the whole I like the special editions
not everything about them and some
things I think are downright awful but I
think it's kind of cool to see still a
mess what they're all working in but as
long as we have the original to always
go back to I don't see The Fault in it I
don't care if you call Canon or not
Canon a version two point five six
whatever it's neat it's like seeing an
artist go back and sketch an old drawing
that he did seeing how the style has
changed take it for what it's worth find
which version you liked the most and
give it a watch
[Music]
everybody knows the Muppets and
everybody loves them but after a few
films then didn't do so great suddenly
the Muppets became really unpopular okay
nobody hated them or anything but they
definitely weren't pulling in all the
numbers once in a while you see him on a
commercial or two but they weren't
really in movies or shows or anything
like that anymore this is why the reboot
movie called The Muppets was such a big
deal not only were they trying to get
people interested again but they threw
as much time and effort into it as
possible we're talking big musical
number celebrities emotional moments new
material mixed with old material
commercials and advertisements
everywhere you went and thankfully it
paid off
not just because it was really really
funny and creative but because it was
brilliantly and brutally honest about
people's acceptance of the Muppets
recently two brothers named Walter and
Gary one of them kind of obviously
adopted are going on a vacation to Los
Angeles one of the reasons being that
Walters biggest dream is to become a
muppet but he finds out that the Muppets
studio is about to be closed and bought
up by an evil tycoon
Sookie rushes to get all the Muppets
back together to put on a great big show
to raise money to keep it around the
problem is all the Muppets have gone
their separate ways why well because
nobody cares about the Muppets anymore
yeah they're pretty harsh and hammering
in how not popular they are
Wow Walter still believes in them as
does Gary well sort of he really just
wants a vacation with his girlfriend
Mary but also wants to help his brother
out and yeah you can see the obvious
problem here will they be able to put on
a show and raise enough money so that
they won't lose the studio Oh what do
you think
no actually doesn't turn out exactly how
you think but in a way it kind of does
but in some ways it's really clever in
other ways it's kind of a cop-out but
okay that's a whole nother video let's
talk about the movie in general the
movie is a send up to the classic
traditional Muppet films like the Muppet
movie or the great Muppet Caper Muppets
Take Manhattan the comedies
straightforward but also strange simple
but with a lot of fourth wall jokes and
does a wonderful job at combining old
tricks with new tricks
classic humor with more modern humor but
that's only what makes it good what
makes it great are the
emotional moments this movie will make
you feel sad that you ever didn't look
at the Muppets there are so many song
sequences and moments of them just
remembering the good old days trying to
figure out what went wrong did they go
south or did the people just leave
something like this can get a little too
heavy-handed but they do it at just the
right balance every single time they
have a song trying to remember what
happened
there's always another song that's very
upbeat and funny and again kind of like
the classic Muppet movies it's this kind
of clever directness that makes us
appreciate them so much more when they
get set up to sing the Rainbow
Connection it's a big tear-jerking scene
but the great thing about is that it
doesn't all rely on nostalgia there's
new stuff as well the new songs are
really great he'll one of them got
nominated for an Academy Award the new
techniques are great combining modern
day technology with well still the fact
that they're foam puppets and it's a
good combination they feel alive they
feel real even though we know they're
obviously just hands in foam but their
personalities are still so strong is so
likable that you just totally overlook
it and accept the madness is it flawless
not really there are a few nitpicks for
example there might be one too many
songs I remember one sequence that Chris
Cooper has I just remember scratching my
head saying what is the purpose of this
it's not especially funny it doesn't
further anything it's just kind of a
weird detour now don't get me wrong most
of them up the movies have weird detours
and yeah I kind of had a problem with
that too doesn't mean I don't have a
problem with it here also I get the idea
that they want Walter to look more human
but I don't know I think he's a very
unimaginative looking muppet
they had him around for a while but then
when they did the new Muppet Show they
didn't even include him in that he's by
no means a bad character each is kind of
a bland wide-eyed innocent he's needed
for the story and he's fine he's just
not that unique I also don't like this
telling at the end seems to rip off
Malcolm in the middle but hey
everybody's ripping off Malcolm the
middle nowadays but play my biggest
issue is the ending and I'll do my best
to talk about without giving anything
away it looks like they're gonna go in
this one direction this direction that
isn't the 100% happy ending but it's
kind of the
eeeh that we'll move on we'll get past
this we're still a family we're still
close we'll still do great things I
thought that was really inspiring at a
great angle but then at the last minute
literally during the credits they just
retconned the whole thing and there's
the 100% happy ending they were just
saying they weren't gonna do that drives
me nuts why do they have to go that
route they could have done something
really new and really different but does
it really ruin anything I don't think so
it's just sort of an ending that I wish
could have been a little different the
majority of the movie hits all the marks
it's supposed to hit when you're
supposed to laugh you laugh when you're
supposed to feel sad you feel sad when
you're supposed to enjoy a really
energetic song sequence you do when it's
supposed to be slow and dramatic it pays
off when it's supposed to be fast and
energetic it's really enjoyable I really
like how the writing in the direction
and the jokes are so similar to those
first three Muffet films yet it isn't
just a mindless retread they throw in
new stuff as well it's a really really
good balance from soothing song numbers
to pointless celebrity cameos to looking
right in the camera and making a joke to
the audience it's the Muppets and
they're right back on track if you love
them at their best you're definitely
gonna love them here
[Music]
after the success of the first film The
Muppets return in Muppets Most Wanted a
movie that literally takes place
directly after the first one yeah you
see them waving and saying goodbye and
then suddenly they're just jumping right
into the sequel I love movies like that
if you wanted you could just edit them
together as one big film that takes some
very strange detour halfway through it's
still funny The Muppets are back at the
Muppets studio but it looks like trouble
is a-brewin as an evil criminal who
happens to look exactly like kermit
breaks in switches them up and now he's
confused for Kermit while the real
Kermit is thrown in jail yeah they're
doing that cheesy story and again even
the Muppets acknowledge they're doing
that cheesy story Walter and a few
others start to catch on and they try to
figure out what's the best way to stop
this criminal mastermind while also
getting Kermit back safely while also
convincing everybody that this guy is
not the real Kermit standard oh yeah but
funny incredibly where I thought the
last Muppet film was very much trying to
be similar to the first Muppet movie
this one is definitely trying to be like
the second Muppet movie the great Muppet
Caper some people didn't really like
that because they liked the emotion of
the last film and and this one it's not
really there but it's not supposed to be
there this one is just returning to the
straight on jokes and clever writing
kitschy song numbers and goofy sequences
and they all work honestly my favorite
Muppet film out of all of them is the
great Muppet Caper even though I love
the emotion of the other ones I just
thought the comedy and the creativity of
that one were so great it was just so
spontaneous and odd but also so
entertaining this one I felt the same
way where the first one has some
problems that we overlooked because the
emotional moments were just so good this
one I think has a lot less most of the
jokes hit bull's eyes and a lot of them
you don't see coming and a lot of them
really do try serve a different humor
while also staying to the traditional
humor that the Muppets are so well known
for it's combining old cliches with new
cliches and there's still all those
pointless celebrity cameos and all these
weird song sequences that just come out
of nowhere the music and lyrics are
incredibly clever so I was kind of
scratching my head why people weren't
getting as into this one as they did
with the first one that's to say I don't
know anyone that hated the movie
but people were either on and didn't
think that much about it or it was okay
the only thing I can gather is that the
first film while it did have more
problems took more risks the emotional
moments in the first one could have very
easily bombed or been awkward or just
didn't pay off which would have caused
people to not only dislike it but really
dislike it but because they took that
risk and it worked a lot of people got a
lot more emotional to it and they
connect it as something much bigger than
the other Muppet movies this one is a
very standard Muppet movie it's really
nothing but jokes even the plot is kind
of one big joke for me
I don't mind that's kind of like what
the traditional Muppets were but for
others they might be wanting something
more
hell even in the opening song they
acknowledge that sequels are usually not
as good as the first one to me that
makes me laugh but to others it might be
like they're kind of admitting that they
know this one's not gonna be that great
and that can put them in kind of a weird
feeling throughout the rest of the film
for me though I loved it I thought it
was hilarious
I do admire the chances that the first
film took more but in terms of what made
me laugh harder that definitely be this
one so I guess it's kind of a pick your
poison if you're going for more of a mix
of the emotional with the laughs that's
definitely the last film but if you're
just going for straight-up comedy this
is definitely the one to check out I
loved it just as much as the other
Muppet films and I know I'm gonna see it
a lot more times in the future
[Music]
okay so a little history if you're
younger and you're watching this you may
notice that when you go to the video
store or a hell if you still go to any
video stores you'll see a lot of Disney
sequels like Cinderella - or the Little
Mermaid - or Lion King - the reason for
this is that there was a time when
hand-drawn animation was dying I mean
okay you could argue it's not really
around much anymore especially
cinematically but Disney was losing it
big time most of their films were not
making money so they did a lot of
direct-to-dvd sequels and most of them
were pretty bad this is worth mentioning
because one or two actually made it to
the big screen and in this case it's
return to Neverland the sequel to one of
Britain's most beloved children's
stories when it came out it was Pan the
critics hated it everybody said it's
just another directed DVD movie just
thrown on the big screen given a little
bit more budget it's a waste of time so
that's the movie I was waiting to see
and honestly I don't think that's what I
got okay it's not great but it was
actually a little better than what I was
expecting
okay sorry okay well it's years later
Wendy has grown up and has a family of
her own but unfortunately it's during
wartime oh yeah we're going there not
only is Wendy's husband going off to war
but it also looks like that her children
one being the main character Jane are
about to get sent away because of the
bombings
Jane has forced herself to grow up
faster than most children because of the
obvious situation while Wendy still
tries to tell stories of Peter Pan and
imagination she just can't seem to get
into him anymore
and understandably so but that all
changes when one night Captain Hook
returns kidnaps Jane and takes her to
Neverland mistaking her for Wendy but
Peter man finds her and saves her and
thus she tries to figure out how to get
back home using her logic and not really
knowing how to use her imagination so
The Lost Boys had to learn how to be
more reasonable even allowing a first
Lost Girl and she has to learn how to be
playful and creative all while avoiding
the evil grasp of the Pirates the major
criticisms that everybody makes about
this movie is that it didn't need to
exist and they're right this doesn't
need to exist the first Peter Pan is
fine exactly how it is both the book and
the play hint that there's other
adventures that go
but it's not something we always
necessarily need to know I guess from me
though I grew up with a show called
Peter Pan and the Pirates it's a show
not a lot of people know about but it
was damn good
it explored never landed explored the
characters and it treated it very very
seriously yeah did that need to exist no
but I would have missed out on all these
great adventures return to Neverland
kinda has a similar feel except in the
Disney universe it's still clearly the
Disney Peter Pan and the Disney Captain
Hook in fact the voices that got to
replace them are amazing they sound just
like the original actors but that
doesn't mean anything if there isn't a
good story to go along with it and this
story yeah it has a little bit of the
lyre revealed elements to it but it
doesn't focus on them that long and all
the other elements they kind of take
from the original book for example
there's a scene where Jane says she
doesn't believe in fairies I saw rolled
my eyes and said oh yeah well we all
know what this is because of the first
movie wait a minute they didn't do that
in the first movie we also have the
manipulation of hook with Wendy except
this time it has to be Jane but this was
a great scene too because it showed that
hook could be very clever he wasn't just
a dumb pirate who waved his sword around
he actually did have a little bit of a
mind and the struggle Jane goes through
is a very understandable struggle you
see the war they show you some of the
grittiness I mean okay not too far they
don't show dead bodies or anything but
they show it stuff she isn't just a
stick in the mud you completely
understand why she has this mindset and
why it's hard for her to imagine things
heck why it's even hard for her to be
happy now with that said there
definitely are things you can complain
about for example they have pop songs oh
yeah and they really don't fit this one
song that the Lost Boys sings that
sounds like a traditional Disney song
beside from that all the songs are sung
by pop singers and their early 2000 pop
singers so they have this grachi but
it's it's supposed to sound tortured and
it sounds like shit it sounds like shit
it's awful it's distracting it's a slap
in the face every time there's supposed
to be an emotional moment I hate it when
they do this with Disney films
especially ones that take place such a
long time ago and in fantasy lands and
you just hear this incredibly dated mm
song and oh it hurts every time
you hear it also the voice actors for
Jane is kind of hit and miss sometimes
she really gets the lines right and
other times it sounds a little forced
but it's nothing too distracting there's
also some weird changes that I never
quite got like instead of a crocodile
they have this giant octopus or squid
something like that and now he's the
thing that chases Captain Hook it's
funny and it's still a enemy well but
why didn't they just do the crocodile
they just say he's gone but why this
octopus thing does the exact same thing
I don't get why they need to switch it
out but for the most part what they do
switch out or keep in it was actually
kind of welcomed and besides that's not
the focus the focus is on Jane
interacting with the Lost Boys and
trying to get back her childhood which
yeah it sounds a little familiar right I
guess if you do have to compare these
two I would say hook is the better movie
but I don't know for a sequel to
Disney's Peter Pan this is kind of
exactly what I would expect it has some
really nice imagery like when hokey is
taking Jane to Neverland this ship is
flying through London it looks amazing
there's a wonderful scene at the end
where young Peter Pan meets grown-up
Wendy and it plays out exactly how it
should play out it's not too emotional
but it's not too simple either it's kind
of how I think of the movie if you're
looking to find problems with it you
won't find any shortage you can
definitely find things that don't quite
work or maybe you've seen in other
movies and such but if you legitimately
want to see a sequel to Peter Pan and
you want to know what happens I think
this is a very delightful adventure I
was really surprised I was not expecting
to like this film I thought I was gonna
hate it like all the other critics did
but I actually kind of enjoyed it it's
not grand or epic but it's simple and
nice did it need to be made probably not
but since it does exist I think it's
fine I think kids can watch it and get a
lot of laughs and adults can watch and
enjoy some of the more emotional moments
it felt like the people making it
enjoyed the subject matter and weren't
forced into doing it they appreciated
the magic and the imagination and the
humor and the artwork and I want to do
something very similar and in my opinion
they succeeded I guess it's not a favor
for a lot of Disney fans but for me I
have no problem believing in fairies
with this one
[Music]
hey you remember wicked that Broadway
show that took the world by storm by
looking at a popular story and giving it
a new point of view and everybody has
been trying to rip off in one way or
another recently well now we have
Disney's version one of many but this is
one that actually takes place in Oz -
its Oz the great and powerful an imagine
if take from director Sam Raimi who
mixes imagination and wonder with
awkwardness and a lot of clumsy choices
a magician played by James Franco wants
to make a name for himself by doing
great things but he just can't seem to
get off the ground well one day he
literally gets off the ground with a
balloon gets sucked away into a storm
and wakes up in the Land of Oz of course
comes across some interesting characters
and some interesting baddies and he
tells everyone that he is in fact a
powerful wizard by using his illusion
sense salesmanship he convinces everyone
he can do great things and for the most
part everybody believes him
but soon an evil witch played by Rachel
Weisz tries to use his tricks to her
advantage while also using her sister
played by Mila Kunis by manipulating her
romantic interest in him to fulfill an
evil plot okay so what are the good
things well as you'd imagine especially
being a Sam Raimi film it is very
visually interesting some of these
backgrounds look a little repeated like
we saw this in Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland or Laura the Rings but then
you get some really cool scenes like the
opening is done in a different aspect
ratio this is obviously supposed to be
very similar to the trick they did in
the first film where it starts off in
black and white and then it goes to
color not only does this start out in
black and white but it's not in
widescreen and even when it's not in
widescreen they use the 3d effects very
cleverly like when someone shoots fire
out or throws a hat it actually goes
outside the boundaries and it works more
to its advantage when you travel to Oz
and they go to widescreen and you see
how vast and gigantic it can be
sometimes I have to admit it does kind
of capture the spirit of the original
Wizard of Oz there's a wonderful scene
where he comes across this little china
doll and tries to glue her back together
everything about this scene is capped
for lack of a better word magical it's
just a magical wonderful little mall
the music the pacing the acting the
effects the effects are unbelievable
here you really feel like this thing is
alive it's a really charming tender
moment that I really wish the rest of
the film was like but sadly it isn't it
just kind of feels like some choices
were made that shouldn't have been made
James Franco can be an unbelievably good
actor but he seems kind of miscast here
I feel like there should have been
someone a little older or a little bit
better at being a fast talker he just
kind of looks like a guy who's trying to
play a con artists not an actual con
artists himself the whole film as you
probably imagine is building up to the
classic liar revealed story and I hate
these stories I think we're all so sick
of it I think we put up with it more of
tons of creative stuff was coming and
yeah there are some really creative
scenes but story wise it goes the route
you think it's gonna go and yeah the
whole time you're watching it you're
thinking huh wasn't this done a lot
better in wicked and speaking of which
let's get to the ultimate blunder in
this movie Mila Kunis as the Wicked
Witch Oh Lord this is a good actress she
can do good stuff but this is completely
the wrong choice it's like having
William Shatner is Hamlet or Leonardo
DiCaprio as the mask just some things
don't go together and you know they're
not gonna go together but you kind of
hope it's like Michael Keaton and Batman
like everyone thought it wasn't gonna
work but maybe it'll play out maybe the
director saw something that nobody else
saw but no the makeup is ridiculous the
voice she has isn't dramatic and it
isn't intimidating it just looks like a
little girl dressing up for Halloween
and screaming I'm the Wicked Witch
believe me I'm the Wicked Witch it's
hard to watch like really hard to watch
and like I said this is a good actress
she has tons of other work to her credit
this just isn't gonna be one of them the
majority of feedback I hear on this
movie is mostly really negative like
people not only dislike this movie they
hate it they just thought it was the
pits well I think some scenes are I
can't quite go that far the liar
revealed story is painful but the rest
of the set up I thought was actually
kind of clever if given a little bit
more focus and a few different choices
made I think this could have been
actually
a really good story and a downright
really great film but as is kind of like
the spider-man movies they're well
intended and creative and visually
interesting but they're just kind of
awkward the moments that work are really
great moments the ones that don't are
just kind of uncomfortable I guess I
wasn't expecting that much I mean I
wasn't especially excited for this movie
so maybe there wasn't as big a
disappointment for me I'm still glad I
saw a certain scenes I like some of
these creative characters I like when
they're flying in the bubbles I like
when he's playing the china doll back
together I like some of this imagery but
clearly some of these casting choices
should have been moved around some of
the dialogue could have been a lot more
clever the pacing in some moments could
have been a little tighter which leads
to an obviously good intentioned but
still clumsy movie if you're in the mood
for some good visuals and a couple of
nice scenes I say this isn't that bad
one to check out but if you're in the
mood for something that's much more
complete and put together I say you're
probably gonna need a lot more glue
[Music]
you know every Christmas I try to review
a good Disney Christmas movie well you
know what I'm sick of it this Christmas
I want to review crap oh this looks good
Beauty and the Beast the enchanted
Christmas this is one of the earlier
Disney sequels that was coming out like
maybe the six or seventh
god it's sad to think that number is
actually early this must have been
really popular because they even
rereleased it with a special edition
yeah I guess this got a bit of a fanbase
I guess to its credit it's not the worst
I mean there's definitely a lot more bad
Disney sequels out there but yeah it's
still not back yeah okay well it takes
place once again once upon a time except
this time Belle and her prints are
talking about who brought Christmas back
to the palace
so we flash back to when Belle was still
a prisoner of the Beast he's still
pretty kind to her in terms of letting
her roam through the castle and
everything but he has this hatred of
Christmas one of the reasons being I
guess they are all transformed on
Christmas huh what a coincidence and
they even come across this Christmas
ornament played by Bernadette Peters who
hates Christmas as well because she
hates what a reminder it is of all the
misery that it's brought but of course
Belle wants to bring Christmas to the
castle by going out and getting a tree
and celebrating the holiday but little
do both her and the Beast know that
they're actually being manipulated by
this evil organ play by Tim Curry oh
yeah now things get good Tim Curry is
the villain in this and he doesn't
really attack or throw anything at beef
oh well not till the end but we'll get
to that he just uses his manipulation to
keep the beef shut off from everybody so
he can do nothing but play music for I
guess on the whole there are a few good
ideas here most of them being around Tim
Curry the design of this organ is
amazing he's all CG but he looks
incredible this is something that
clearly should be CG the film also looks
very nice well okay it's pretty
impressive for the animation that they
had at the time this was before they
just abandoned their film animation
threw it all into their DVDs look this
was kind of a nice half way it wasn't as
lame looking as return of Jafar but it
wasn't as good-looking as a Mulan too
they still have some nice winter and
Airmen's they know how to shoot the snow
they know how to get some good colors in
there and I guess if someone was forced
to do a Christmas beauty and the beast'
special this is not the worst story you
could put to it I can't like the idea of
keeping the Beast away from everybody
and the organ is kind of being like this
addiction trying to keep him in his
loneliness in fact he actually kind of
likes his new form and he wants to stay
in that new form isn't that fascinating
but aside from that it's not much Belle
goes from being a really interesting
character to just always kind of being
happy and smiling and optimistic a
little too much she becomes a little too
bland it's nice hearing Bernadette
Peters sing but he'll anytime she sings
it's amazing one of the problems though
is that the songs are very half-assed
that is to say I'm sure someone worked
very hard on them but all of them sound
like melodies that just weren't given
enough time to really blue they're all
kind of searching for a sound or
searching to be the next be prepared or
Beauty and the Beast love song and yeah
they just sort of sound like cheap
imitations they weren't given enough
time to be those songs there's also this
completely pointless climax where it
looks like everything is gonna end but
how to know where the organ decides no
I'm gonna stop everybody I'm gonna
destroy the castle and oh what the hell
are you doing I give it credit that it
could have been a lot more half-assed
you get a feeling that the people
working on this are kind of drugging
like okay well if we have to do this
let's try to put something decent
together but with an idea this strange
in this forest it's really hard to turn
out anything that's spectacular
especially after this was such a
spectacular movie with the originals
it's a pretty damn tough follow-up
I guess I'd say if you're very forgiving
of story and characters and you're just
kind of looking for some basic Christmas
visuals that aren't spectacular but are
good
this is harmless but yeah coming off the
heels of the only enemy film at the time
that was nominated for Best Picture
you'd probably expect something a little
better than this but then again it's a
direct-to-dvd Christmas special what can
you expect I wasn't impressed but I
wasn't horrified either there's plenty
of stupid moments but there's some okay
moments as well in my opinion there are
some
Christmas specials out there that do
this kind of stuff so much better that
it's definitely worth looking at those
instead if you got the nostalgia factor
fair enough go ahead and watch it it's
not gonna injure you any and hey this is
what gets you in the holiday spirit Who
am I to judge
Merry Christmas and I'll see you through
the rest of December
[Music]
well after the surprise enjoyment of
return to Neverland a kind of good
Disney sequel I was suddenly reminded of
the bad Disney sequels with Jungle Book
- by no means an awful movie but
definitely a 100% completely pointless
one there is no reason to continue this
story there is no reason to see these
characters again the first one ended on
a perfect note
Mowgli goes where he's supposed to go
and the animals go where they're
supposed to go so if you're gonna do a
sequel to this you should make it really
interesting he'll even the original book
had a sequel and it's very very
interesting effect it's downright
depressing let's see how the first film
barely followed the book I was expecting
this one would either not only was I
right
I was really disappointing Lee right
Mowgli is still a little boy and still
in the man village a family decides to
take him in he even manages to get a
little bit of a romantic acquaintance
that is as much as boys like girls at
that age but he finds the jungle is
still calling him so one day after
getting in a fight with his family he's
suddenly out of nowhere feels like he
doesn't belong and decides to run away
and thus finds Baloo Bagheera and all
his animal friends his girlfriend
decides to chase after him but little do
they all know that sheera khan is back
and once revenge from mowgli humiliating
him in the past
will he slice into ribbons while they
sing bare necessities of minimum four
times oh how I wished as some of you
know I wasn't really the biggest fan of
the first jungle book that is to say it
was good it was fine I just really wish
there was a better rendition of the
story told but it's okay it's passable
so obviously in the sequel they try to
relive a bunch of scenes that you
remember from the first movie look
there's Karl
look there's the elephants look there's
the vultures and that's really about it
the only things that are kinda new in
this is the opening and the ending the
opening where you see Mowgli in the man
village which honestly could have been
developed a lot more I think it's a
little too happy in the ending where
there's a climax in the ruins of an old
temple
that wasn't me for a bit but aside from
that it's literally just going from
character to character scene to scene
saying hey you remember this you
remember this yeah I do remember this in
fact like
just put on the first movie to watch it
they just go from one distracting song
to another distracting song actually not
even a different distracting song most
the time is just bare necessities the
romance between Mowgli and the girl
isn't very interesting the new
characters they do introduce just seem
kind of pointless I get the feeling this
was intended for little little kids and
I guess as a story for little little
kids go
it'll entertain them for a bit but again
it's Disney and it's the Jungle Book
don't you think a little bit more time
and effort would go into the development
of this I mean on a technical level it's
not bad the animation is still really
nice especially on the human characters
the voice actors are good choices with
Haley Joel Osment Mowgli and Jung
Goodman as Baloo as well as Tony J
playing Shir Khan and Jim Cummings as
kha these are all good replacements but
just makes you feel all the worse that's
being wasted on a story that just has no
reason to be nothing is discovered
nothing is really furthered it just kind
of goes back to what you did in the
first film and even then I don't think
I'm giving anything away here he just
kind of goes back to where he belongs
which yeah that's kind of what happened
the first film wasn't it with Disney
doing another live-action remake of this
story and it looks like they're gonna
stick to the animated film once again
it's such a shame to think we will never
see a movie version of this book that's
supposed to be like the book I just
never got outside of the Chuck Jones
short why we never got this version on
the big screen it's interesting and kids
would watch it and adults would watch it
it's the one time a dark gritty reboot
would be totally welcomed but as someone
who thought the first film was okay at
best this one just left me completely
empty and I think most people forget it
immediately after they watch it I feel
bad because there's obviously a lot of
work and talent that went into making it
but unless you do something new or
interesting I think I'm gonna stay out
of the jungle
for a while
[Music]
people are always so split when it comes
to Cinderella
some say it's a charming fairytale
others say it's an incredibly sexist
story I guess I'm somewhere in between I
mean yeah de Cinderella really have to
stay with that family could she have
left at any time probably but if the
story is done right you focus on the
things that are the most important like
how being a hopeful patient loving and a
hard worker can finally pay off this is
the idea they were trying to do with the
new Cinderella that in my opinion
doesn't really come across the story
still seems basically on track
Cinderella is a young girl who has a
father that she loves very much but he
tragically passes away leaving her with
her stepmother and stepsisters the three
of them don't like Cinderella and
immediately start to treat her like a
slave trying to be optimistic she obeys
all their commands hoping one day to
accept their love but she slowly started
to realize it's never gonna happen
she bumps into a young man who happens
to be a prince and they start to hit it
off until they find out their situation
and realize that they're probably never
gonna be anything more than friends if
even that but the father wants the
prince to marry and so they hold a great
big ball for him to socialize the
stepmother and stepsister don't let her
go to the ball but of course a fairy
godmother comes and shows her the way
through kindness and magic she
transforms a pumpkin into a carriage and
her rags into a beautiful dress her
shoes into glass slippers and she's off
to the ball she once again hits it off
with the prince but she needs to leave
resulting in one of her slippers being
left behind and thus the maiden who can
fit the slipper will marry the prince
sounds pretty standard to the
traditional Disney formula but there are
a few changes some good some bad let's
talk about the good stuff seeing how -
Kenneth Branagh film once again it looks
amazing the colours the sets the
Scimitar Effie it's like you're really
in a fairy tale there's a lot more
detail given two characters that didn't
get much attention in the original that
sorely needed it for example the prince
is much more fleshed out yeah he isn't
just a bit of hunk arm candy he's
actually a very interesting character as
is the king and even the stepmother has
a little bit more development as we
actually see her and the husband tried
to get along tried to have a little bit
of a life together but realise that
they're not quite meant for one another
so you see the seeds of how she would
become so despicable it's also kind of
interesting seeing the development of
Cinderella starting off as the
stepdaughter then slowly becoming the
maid they don't just immediately say go
to the kitchen they say Oh would you
like to help out wouldn't you like to
make things easier leading to a point
where they don't even let her sit at the
same table anymore which is the scene
where she finally breaks down it's
emotionally affective you really feel
bad that she will never be a part of
this family I also kind of liked the
idea that the fairy godmother is
disguised as a peasant but then when
Cinderella treats her with kindness
that's when she gives her the reward a
good lesson but isn't the idea that
she's being rewarded for kindness all
fear in life it's kind of weird that she
suddenly gets all this stuff just for
treating one person in a good way
but whatever you get the idea honestly
the film in many respects does do a lot
of good updates that is except for one
element that is kind of an important
element and that's Cinderella herself if
you watch the interviews they all talk
about how she's not a damsel in distress
and she's not a waif and I really hate
it when they do that because it's like
okay we know what she's not what is she
then the answer is not very interesting
ironically in trying to make the
character more strong and independent
they actually make her more submissive
and more dependent in the original
cartoon her father dies when she's a
child so it makes sense that she would
be used to this way of living that she's
supposed to be the servant here he dies
when she's practically an adult so it
doesn't make any sense why she wouldn't
just leave in fact there's a scene where
friends are asking her why don't you
just leave and she's like oh it's my
father's place I would feel bad that
makes no sense and she ends up leaving
at the end anyway so it makes doubly no
sense and when it does show her
childhood it's some of the worst stuff
in the movie it actually starts off
showing how over-the-top Pleasant her
life is and it is painful it is beyond
sappy it's like it's made for
three-year-olds which if the movie was
made for three-year-olds fine but it's
clearly not it's supposed to be made for
everybody it's supposed to make adults
feel like children and children like
adults just know if you're watching it
the first couple minutes is not a
reflection of the rest of the film and
following that over-the-top happy
childhood she herself is also
over-the-top happy there's one scene
where she finally breaks down it's a
very welcome scene but all the other
times she just kind of smiles and looks
Pleasant
I'm sorry that's not interesting I know
a lot of people remember the original
Cinderella as being just very bland and
not very interesting but you know what
she had her limits she could get angry
she could get frustrated you could see
in the animation the performance that
she's constantly telling herself just
get through it just get through it so
when it leads to the scene where the
dress is ripped apart and she has
nothing left it's genuinely
heartbreaking in this movie when they
rip the dress apart it doesn't mean a
thing yeah she cries and she feels sad
but it feels like we're going through
this simply because it's the Cinderella
story we kind of got to go through it it
didn't feel burned we already had the
big cry scene when she realizes she is
in part of the family and it was very
effective but because of that you're
taking away from a moment that should
have been huge because you did it a
little too early on top of that there's
a scene at the end where she's locked in
the Attic now in the original she tries
to get out she's banging on the door
she's calling for help in this one she's
just so happy thinking about her prince
and also somehow so sad that she thinks
nobody would want to see her that she
does nothing she just spins around
singing to herself oh my god this is
supposed to be the stronger more
independent version a good strong
character is supposed to work with their
flaws you're supposed to see what their
problems are and see them work through
it
the original Cinderella is trying to
work through a mindset that she's had
since childhood and see that she is
worth the effort she's worth breaking
out she's worth going behind her
stepmother and stepsisters back here
much more than the original she waits
for someone to come and save her in the
original she's at least making an
attempt to get out I'm sorry these are
big problems with this character so does
I make it a bad movie kinda I mean it is
called Cinderella so you would think
Cinderella should be good and
interesting but it's kind of hard seeing
how they update all these other elements
the prince is more interesting the King
is more interesting the stepmother is
interesting there's less of cute little
mice and more chemistry between the
romantic leads somewhere between this
live-action version and the anime
version there's a really good rendition
of Cinderella that's waiting to get out
honestly if you want a good one that
actually has an interesting character
and tells the story in a unique awesome
way go see ever after
in my opinion the most fun an
interesting rendition of the Cinderella
story with a smart interesting complex
lead with this one it is difficult to
like if you don't make your main
character relatable where the original
did have problems that were just kind of
problems of Disney fairy tales in the
day this one updates some but then makes
others a little worse I guess I'm glad I
saw it I mean it did look interesting
and it was very elegant and pretty it
obviously tried really hard it just
tried so hard in some areas that it got
lost and confused about what it actually
was getting across it's hard to say if
you're looking for just a nice little
fairy tale where women wear pretty
dresses and dance with princes and such
you'll like it fine if you want to feel
more emotion than you did the original
Cinderella I don't know if you're gonna
give much of that because like I said
it's just hard to relate with this
character I guess it's just kind of a
pick your poison
grab a pumpkin and see for yourself
[Music]
you
the plot to Tomorrowland seems eerily
similar to what the film actually is the
movie is about a place where every
creative dreamer is taken and allowed to
explore any creative idea they want with
no limitations essentially that's the
film in a nutshell a whole bunch of
interesting and Imagi t'v ideas with
absolutely no limitations but the thing
is you kind of need limitations if not
you get kind of this disorganized
unfocused mess and yeah you can start to
see where the problem is the movie opens
with a rather awkwardly and funny
introduction by George Clooney who tells
the story about how he used to be a boy
genius he creates a rocket pack yeah
it's that kind of movie I guess and an
Android that looks like a little girl
takes into that wonderful place where
all creativity is welcome Tomorrowland
cut to modern day where another little
genius named Casey is given a pin that
allows her to see Tomorrowland but not
quite get there when she tries to look
for more information about it suddenly
robots and all sorts of villains are
chasing her down the little Android from
before named Athena comes back into play
and she leads her to George Clooney who
in turn takes her to Tomorrowland why
because he apparently created a device
that could depict the end of the world
and guess what it's coming up but this
calculations show that Casey might be
the key in order to fix everything will
they make it in time and stop an evil
genius played by Hugh Laurie from making
this self-fulfilling prophecy come true
this Disney like really obvious tie-ins
to its theme parts literally having the
opening take place at one of their theme
parks I think you know the answer to
this okay so I'll start off with the
worst part the opening is awful the
writing it's horrendously bad
this is so weird cuz this is a Brad Bird
film he's usually very good at directing
this kind of stuff but ma'am every line
is about dreaming and wishing and
whimsical Ness and following your heart
and all that stupid stuff you hear on
Disney Channel movies just repeat it
over and over and over everything they
say is like a mini speech just nobody
talks normal when I first start watching
it I was thinking to myself oh man am I
in for a bad ride but luckily it does
get a lot better like when you do
finally see Tomorrowland it's very
impressively done and most of it just
done in one shot the action and comedy
get a lot better too with a lot of
creative inventions and fight scene
and on top of that they start throwing
in some really interesting ideas for
example Clooney when he was a little boy
falls in love with the Android naturally
he's gonna get older and she's not also
on top of the fact that she's an Android
and quote-unquote can't feel loved
this could so easily be uncomfortable
seeing a grown man like George Clooney
kind of talking to this little girl that
he used to be attracted to but it's
played just right so you feel more the
tragedy of it rather than the creepiness
of it I know it sounds weird downward
disturbing but it's actually kind of
handled pretty well and as you guess a
lot of the ideas behind the technology
is very inventive the device that lets
you see into the future in the way it
operates is very cleverly done just
watching it you get a feeling like you
could handle it I love movies that work
that way like you feel like you could
actually kind of operate these things in
the trailers they show Tomorrowland it
looks grand and phenomenal but in the
movie that's all you see in fact it's
not even the real thing without giving
away too much because actually it's kind
of a clever twist but when you do
actually get there it's very empty and
lifeless I know that's the point but
wasn't the whole focus of this movie to
see Tomorrowland we get one incredible
long tracking shot and that's it it's
cool but that's the name of the movie
Tomorrowland it should look awesome on
top of that because there's so much
going on it's so much information thrown
at you so quickly it's kind of hard to
understand at times
for example Hugh Laurie says that the
world is doomed but Tomorrowland is
gonna be fine well if that's the case
how come nobody's in Tomorrowland
anymore how come it almost looks
destroyed there's also this great big
long speech that's kind of explaining
why Hugh Laurie thinks the world kind of
should blow up and I don't know I can't
tell if it's actually really profound or
super preaching bottom line it's so
complicated you're still not quite sure
what the motivation is now don't get me
wrong a movie that really wants to
challenge you it's a different
philosophies and such that's welcomed
but the movie literally opened up with a
little boy creating a rocket pack and
flying it around Tomorrowland how are we
supposed to follow this incredibly
complicated philosophical technobabble
is this a fun little fantasy or a super
liberal that's trying to write out all
his aggressions even the acting seems on
and off Jorge Klee sometimes can be very
charming but then other times
his comedic timing is really off same
thing with Casey sometimes she talks
like someone her age and then other
times she just sounds so over-the-top
whimsical and shoving the message in
your face that's just irritating the
only thing that's constantly good
through it is the Android they pick a
really good actress to play her and yes
she has to do some very complicated
unique scenes with George Clooney and
this kind of not really sort of romance
that was going on
but she completely pulls it off and
she's totally convincing she's easily
the best part of the movie as for the
rest I don't know it kind of feels like
it's trying to be a dark and gritty Meet
the Robinsons except where the message
in that one well also hammered in was
kept very simple this one the entire
world depends on it if everybody doesn't
follow their dreams we're all gonna be
destroyed it just seems a little too
extreme for me and much like the idea
behind the world itself I feel it does
knee limitations it does need people to
say maybe not this maybe we should try
something else it's a cool thought to
see creativity just bloom and never be
filtered but I think the moral of the
story would have been more interesting
if they was showing that limitations are
needed compromises are gonna have to be
made I'm still happy I saw it it for
anything else just for a lot of these
creative and unique ideas but tone wise
it's all over the place sometimes it
feels very adult sometimes it feels
unbelievably childish sometimes the
effects are amazing sometimes they're
ridiculous sometimes it's whimsical
sometimes it's boring sometimes it's
slow sometimes it's too fast it's about
it's an even a film as you can get me
personally I like it when ideas are so
prompt in my brain and can sort fit all
around in there so I can definitely take
that from it but if you're looking for a
movie that's much more put together and
easy to follow sadly it seems like it's
another dream away
[Music]
well here's a first I'm actually doing a
river view of a Disney cember I did
hocus-pocus as a lie you know what I saw
this film I really didn't like it in
fact I downright hated it to a point
where people were asking for years for
me to do a nostalgia critic of it I
finally did I sat down watched it again
and yeah I still didn't like it but I
will admit it wasn't quite as bad as I
remembered the Whoopi it was pretty
obvious and what I'm trying to say but
if you wanted a more down-to-earth talk
about it I guess that's what this video
is for so let's address the things I
didn't like about originally the big
focus was the virgin talk everybody gave
this kid such a hard time for him being
a virgin hell it's even the final line I
always remember that being a problem and
while it still is I'll admit it's not as
bad as I remember even when I did the
movie review I made a conscious effort
not to mention it as many times as the
movie does which i think is something
like four or five times that's still
weird but yeah it's wrong to say it's
the focus of the entire film I brought
up how the witches don't have anything
funny to say and that's still true but
watching it again I realize even though
they really don't have anything plain to
say they still kind of say it in a funny
way these three actresses are actually
really enjoyable you can't get the
feeling two weren't given anything to
work with but they just said screw it
we're gonna throw our all into every
single moment we're on screen and it
shows I get the feeling they sort of
huddled together and talked about how
they're gonna move in what each one is
gonna do when the camera starts rolling
does that excuse the bad writing no but
it does kind of make it a little
entertaining these three are a lot of
fun to watch now does that excuse how
incredibly bland the main characters are
no does that excuse how this story makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
no does that excuse a lot of really
awkward just downright stupid moments
absolutely not
but over time I am realizing more and
more why this is getting a following and
that the correct terminology for it
really is guilty pleasure it's like my
love for Ernest saves Christmas it is a
stupid movie and nothing makes sense
about it but some things are just so
good I can't help but watch it every
hocus pocus I can now see is kind of the
same way there is a lot of Halloween in
it there are a lot of nice visuals it's
over-the-top and cartoony but that just
kind of makes it stand out even more the
song sequence with her singing is a lot
of fun a lot of the effects actually
still kind of hold up and even all those
cliche 90s tropes I think people are
kind of laughing at how cliched they are
now and how you did see them just in
every kid's movie at the time it doesn't
mean it's by any means smart but I can
see how people can be really entertained
by it it's not for me to say I actually
enjoy it but I do enjoy parts enough to
at least finally see why other people
enjoy it and I think that's an important
thing to understand so I guess the
conclusion of this re-review is if
you're really forgiving and just want to
see some Halloween visuals you'll
probably be satisfied here or if you
really like those classic 90s tropes and
you just kind of want to have a laugh at
them you'll probably really like this
too I still really don't like those
scenes where they address the whole
weird virgin shaming but like I said
it's not as focused on as I remember it
so maybe the majority of kids watch it
will probably overlook that too and just
be distracted by how entertaining the
three witches are I just felt like this
movie deserved a second chance do I
still like it no but I can understand
why others liked it if this is something
you watch every Halloween I finally get
it I probably won't be joined the group
but I can at least say there are some
really fun and weird things about it
that you can get a few laughs at I'll
enjoy my incredibly silly stupid guilty
pleasures and you can enjoy yours
[Music]
well for years I said my favorite Pixar
movie is up but now that has finally
changed to inside out not only the best
Pixar film ever written but one of the
best Disney films I've ever seen this is
a movie that takes an idea and does
everything great that you can do with it
the setup is that everybody's mind is
fuelled by emotions and here the
emotions are personalized they're
basically what you would think joy is
very happy sandesh is very depressed
fear is very paranoid you get the idea
we focus on the emotions of a girl named
Riley who's moving from one new location
to another such a large change is
throwing her emotions out of whack and
we find that joy and sadness are
accidentally separated from headquarters
and trapped off somewhere else
thus the movie is just them trying to
get back in order to bring balance back
to Riley's emotional state in doing so
joy and sadness to polar opposites have
to find a way to get along in order to
work together now the idea of emotions
having personalities in your head is
nothing new this has been done in Warner
Brothers cartoons Disney cartoon and
hell there's even a sitcom about called
Herman's head but this is the first one
that said maybe we can not only do
something funny with this but also
really dramatic something that anybody
of any age can understand the story is
actually a coming-of-age story talking
about change talking about adapting
talking about sacrifices talking about
how some things have to be pushed out of
your mind and replaced with others and
all the hardships of growing up are
showing through these characters who are
developing Riley as she goes through
these tough moments whether you're a kid
going through these moments or an adult
who used to go through these moments
everybody can sympathize you get these
problems you get these frustrations you
understand how hard it is to adapt but
at the same time it balances out with a
lot of bright colors and funny moments
and goofy moments which is really what
the film is about balance joy and
sadness don't get along but like a lot
of buddy movies they realize that they
have to get along well here it actually
serves a purpose joy is the one who's
usually in charge and tries to keep
sadness off to the sidelines but the
movie so brilliantly shows how much joy
and sadness are actually tied together I
won't give away but let's just say it's
brilliant it's summed up through visuals
that everybody can understand
and everybody can relate to so many of
us try to run away from sandesh we think
it's not healthy but this movie shows
it's unbelievably healthy all your
emotions are healthy you just have to
know how to keep them in check the movie
shows it's okay to feel however you feel
there's no shame in feeling sad there's
no shame in feeling angry if anything by
confronting them you create new emotions
and new moments and the best thing is it
sticks to the choices they make when
they move they stay moved when a
character has to disappear he stays
disappeared they don't pull any
happily-ever-after reckoning stuff no
they mean this stuff for serious because
it's all part of growing up and you're
gonna have to go through hardships and
you're just gonna have to accept it it's
so great that a movie about emotions
talks about all this in fact it's the
perfect movie to talk about all this
with all the unnecessary Pixar sequels
coming out this is one of the few that I
would love to see a sequel to I would
love to see movies that follows Riley
into adulthood
the same way the toys and Toy Story grow
up with Andy I would love to see the
emotions grow up with Riley what new
developments can we relate to and in
what creative way would they show it
there's so many opportunities with this
idea in fact if you watch the blu-ray
you can see all the other ideas they
were gonna do but couldn't because there
wasn't enough time they're all great and
I'd love to see more of these come about
this is a movie that not only leaves me
wanting more it leaves me wanting a lot
more why can't this get a spinoff
universe why can't this have other
stories and other characters that can
lead to other movies to me that's the
sign of a really really good flick I
guess if I really have to nitpick the
only problem I have is that it could
have been a little funnier like there's
a scene where they had to wake up this
scary clown in order to give her a
nightmare that thing could have been a
lot scarier and led to a lot more comedy
there's a few lines and a few scenes I
thought could have used just a little
bit more of a punch to it well I
definitely laughed out a lot of scenes I
wasn't laughing super hard at least not
as much as some of the other Pixar films
but like I said it's a nitpick really
everything from the most part balances
out incredibly well I still laughed at
the right moments I still cried at the
right moments quite fittingly every
emotion that's supposed to play out
plays out every time I see it it gets
better
better the stories the characters the
layout it's just phenomenal in my
opinion it's as perfect a Pixar movie as
you can get and definitely a good one to
end this Disney cember on thank you all
once again for watching I hope you
enjoyed and yeah maybe in January I'll
do a few by popular demands again but
for this year it's great to see that
Disney is still dishing out the
creativity and new ideas and continuing
to inspire thank you all so much for
joining me and I'll see you next year
[Music]
by popular demand its Mars Needs Moms
yeah sorry it took so long to get to
these we've kind of been busy with a few
other things but here I am and I finally
saw one of Disney's biggest
disappointments the critical and
box-office flop that actually destroyed
Robert Zemeckis 'as motion capture
company yep remember Polar Express
Beowulf Christmas Carol you're gonna see
nothing like that anymore because this
is the film that killed it some would
say that's a shame others would say
thank God because of the kept turning up
films like this yeah it's not a big loss
the film was about a little boy who's
having trouble getting along with his
mother only to discover she's being
kidnapped by aliens and he follows along
they're taken to a planet that's ruled
by females who have absolutely no idea
how to take care of children huh then
how did they survive all these years
okay we'll get all that the boy comes
across another guy who is taken hostage
long ago
and while he doesn't like what they do
he just sort of learns to accept it
because he has no other choice but the
boy says he does have a choice and thus
the two of them as well as an alien
graffiti artist decide to change how
Mars works fight the evil repressive
system and stop all the mothers from
being destroyed oh yeah when the mothers
out use their usefulness they just blow
them up it's too kind of a major problem
of this movie okay I know they always
say don't judge a movie by its title but
the title of this movie is Mars Needs
Moms
okay it's stupid it's one of the worst
titles for a movie ever but at least
when you hear it you get an idea what
you're going to get something playful
something goofy and colorful kind of
light-hearted but no this is a really
dark miserable-looking even intense film
this is humor one of the characters
talks about seeing his mother actually
get destroyed right in front of his eyes
and it's told really slowly and really
dramatically and all I can think to
myself is Mars Needs Moms but no one
really matter if the film was say
creative or charming or imaginative and
it's surprisingly not I know the idea of
this world is that supposed to be
repressive and there isn't any color but
come on even for a repressive world
we've seen this a million times
it looks like Tron it looks like 1984 it
looks like The Matrix it looks like all
these movies we've seen with misery
world the bajillion times and it's just
not interesting anymore I guess the idea
of a race run by females and all the
males are just kind of left in the
garbage is kind of interesting but even
then I'm not really sure what kind of
commentary they're trying to get across
if any is this like a wicker man remake
is women taking over a good thing or a
bad thing or this is supposed to show
ironically how like how men treat women
or women treat matter I don't know maybe
there is no commentary maybe it's just
the way this planet does things and they
just need an enemy to go after and
that's exactly what this film feels like
it feels like everything is there just
so it can kind of be there a kid travels
to Mars because kids want to travel to
Mars they fight oppressive systems
because kids like fighting oppressive
systems Hey look how much they argue
with their parents we're gonna motion
capture Seth Green as the little kid
even though he doesn't do any of the
voice because we just kind of motion
capture celebrities for some reason at
least with Tom Hanks and Jim Carrey they
were in the movie they got to use their
voices but Seth Green I mean he's a fine
actor but did you absolutely need this
guy in this role I can tell you that his
addition doesn't add anything nor any of
the characters John Cusack she's one of
my favorite actresses she is so funny
and so entertaining yet she's just there
to kind of be there for Phil about kewda
wants to go save his mother they don't
make this mother interesting at all
and it's such a shame to hear someone I
know it's so uniquely fun like Joan
Cusack just given nothing to work with
so I guess if you're just in a mood to
save fight the power and the repressive
whatever is as a those films do well
sometimes this one definitely doesn't
make any sense but I guess if you just
want to get that rebellious emotion out
of your system but outside from that I
have no idea who would enjoy this film
it's not the worst it's just dull and
when it's not dull it's kind of
unpleasant and for a movie called Mars
Needs Moms you wouldn't expect something
so grim and depressing in terms of at
least seeing a yearly film with motion
capture that's gonna look like a really
high budget production they're pretty
much extinct now again it's hard to say
this is a good thing or a bad thing but
they're anything like this film I can
say we definitely trade it up
[Music]
by popular demand its Muppet Treasure
Island why are the popular demands this
year films that didn't do financially
well well whatever this is the second
muffin film to be an actual adaptation
of the literary classic the first one
being the previous film Christmas Carol
and what Christmas Carol being such a
big hit you would think audiences would
go and see this one as well but from
what I hear it didn't do so hot and I'd
be lying if I said I didn't see why but
at the same time look it's Tim Curry Tim
Curry with the Muppets he practically is
a muppet this is a match made in heaven
okay well let's look at the story as if
you don't know it's pretty much the
story of Treasure Island a young boy
named Jim Hawkins comes across a
treasure map this leads to a giant
expedition only this time the captain is
played by Kermit the Frog and the
majority of the cast seem to be Muppets
as well that is of course or the Cook
Long John Silver played by Tim Curry by
God is this a match made in heaven and
yes it's just as entertaining as you
think it would be I don't think I'm
giving anything away by saying this but
Long John Silver has an evil plan and
he's gonna mutiny the ship to find the
treasure and yeah come on you've all
read the book you know what happens it
sticks pretty close to it for the most
part it still has a lot of Muppet isms
that most of the time are welcomed the
only strange thing is that one of the
most popular Muppet characters and Miss
Piggy doesn't come in until the last
third in fact the more I think about it
she didn't get much of a rolling
Christmas carol either did she I guess
neither of these stories had that big a
focus on women so you can kind of
understand why but come on you're
already taking so many liberties in
other areas why couldn't you get Miss
Piggy in there at least a lot earlier
but much like Christmas Carol it does
try to really stick to the source
material and kind of the feel just like
I said this time with Muppets in the
part they'll have little fourth wall
jokes who have songs that suddenly come
out of nowhere and kind of like Muppet
Christmas Carol it's fine
I guess people had a little bit more of
a connection with Christmas Carol
because hey it's Christmas it's already
gonna be a sentimental connection and be
there did seem to be a little bit more
heart to it maybe just because of the
story it is with this one it just kind
of feels like a longer ma
good show sketch at least with the
Muppets when it needs to be serious with
Jim Hawkins and stuff it does it fine I
mean it's not the best telling or
anything but it's totally passable
the songs are just as good as Christmas
Carol - I actually loved the intro song
so much I put on my top 11 favorite
villain songs list in Hans Zimmer who I
swear can do no wrong does the
orchestrations for these songs and they
sound pretty badass except when they're
not supposed to some minutes I mean you
know how it works and speaking of
singing silliness let's talk about Tim
Curry this is a guy who even if he does
a bad performance
it'll still be a good performance
there's just some kind of magic to him
that makes it so much fun to watch I
can't even really decide if this is a
good performance or not it's just
insanely entertaining just seeing him
look down to cover the Frog give us a
little girl captain I mean how can you
not fall in love with this guy though to
his credit he does manage to get a nice
connection with Jim Hawkins as well as
he's supposed to in the story and yeah
whether you want to see it as it's so
awkward it's charming or it's so
charming it's awkward he does really
work in the role I almost wouldn't mind
seeing him in another renditions to
Treasure Island where he is Long John
Silver like a serious one but that's not
what this is this is a bunch of hand
puppets trying to retell this story in a
goofy way with some serious moments and
I think it just kind of depends on what
mood you're in there's nothing really
spectacular about I mean even monthly
Christmas have more of a visual sense
than this one did but if you say the
title outloud Muppet Treasure Island
with Tim Curry and you say to yourself
it might be a little fun that's exactly
what you'll get I get the feeling
there's better renditions of this tale
but as one that has little Muppets going
around singing songs and such it's
totally fine
shiver your Timbers and find out for
yourself
you
[Music]